[Music]
e
the
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
welcome welcome everyone from the
beautiful city of St Louis America's
chess Capital we are here in the 2015 US
Chess Championship and the 2015 US
Women's Chess Championship it's a nice
day outside and we hope the storm comes
on the
board
we are now just getting ready for the
second round of the US Women's and US
Chess Championship we see most of the
people of the players arriving Sam
Shanklin seems to be a little bit early
today yeah already focusing on a very
important matchup
absolutely welcome everybody hello
Alejandro welcome to the show it's great
to have you on board it's a pleasure to
be here I'm here in the honor of the
presence of four time US champion Yer
sah come on always always a pleasure
working with you yaser absolutely
absolutely and the pairings today are
going to be great we've got every
round's going to be a tough round and
who do we have in the
open in the open section we have a lot
of interesting matchups the young
talented players Kaden trough and Daniel
naroditsky will be facing each other
both of them started with losses so they
want to get back on the scoreboard one
of the key match ups today Sam Shanklin
will be playing Wes Lea then the
youngster Sam seian will be trying his
medal against the current ringing
Champion gakamsky Karu Nakamura and baru
jobian will be playing in a very
important matchup the both players won
their first round and want to keep their
perfect score while Teo G will hope to
move to 4-0 in his personal score
against Conrad Holt he will be wi for
the fourth time in a row and in a very
difficult match up for both players Ray
opson will be playing his former coach
Alex
ANUK in the women's section we have a
perva verk could playing against Nat
bid reigning US Women's Champion Arena
Crush will try to go for her first
victory of the tournament against
Victoria ni while rusan goani who has
not as active as of recent will be
playing against Sabina fure who had the
win in hand yesterday but let her go
also with a win in hand was krina and
SOA who will be playing Black against
Anna sharich who pulled a little bit of
a miracle yesterday and that was against
one of the youngest players in the
tournament Jennifer Yu who will be
blocking against the youngest player of
the tournament Annie Wang and in a
battle of players that absolutely have
to win to get back in the tournament
Alisa milina will be playing White
against TF
abrahamian so yaser tell me a little bit
about yesterday's games well uh nervous
start nervous start start for round one
This Is Us Championship strongest
youngest ever and I think the players
going to get settled for today I saw too
many mistakes for this high quality a
tournament I really expected some really
much better games than we saw yesterday
and I'm sure the players feel the same
way having said that I think a big game
today is hikaru's game against VAR
kobian last year VAR made it to the
finals he lost
in the finals to gakamsky but uh these
two players have played a lot against
each other they're very familiar the
very the very good Grand Masters and uh
hikaro like you said needs to win and
keep his winning streak Al light and
going over the key matchups this with us
grandmas Maurice
Ashley well guys yesterday as you said
yes was a nervous day we saw lots of
mistakes blunders on some of the boards
but nevertheless it's Fighting Chess and
this is what we want to see here at the
US championships and US Women's
championships everyone wants a piece of
a point no matter how they can get it
and we're going to see some key matchups
today first of all on the men's side two
young players Sam Shanklin and Wesley so
two of the top players in the
competition Sam when I spoke to him in
Hawaii at a recent event that we both
shared I said how you going to win this
what are your chances he said I've got
to beat the Top Guns well he's facing a
Top Gun right now in Wesley so who's
currently number six in the world in the
live rankings so that'll be a very
difficult matchup for him he's got a lot
to prove and he's at the board early
with his game face on in the other
matchup key matchup of the game on the
women's side anes sharich played some
incredible chess yesterday I used the
word incredible tongue and cheek mean
she sacked a pawn sacked another one
then sacked a piece she probably should
have lost that game but she managed to
pull it out with Fighting Chess she'll
be going up against the Czech Katarina
neova who also played figh fighting
chest yesterday and didn't manage to win
her game these two are veterans they
know how to win big games Anna has won
four championships in her native belus
while mova has played for the Olympic
team so we're talking about a great
matchup today it should be a fun round
with with other key matchups as well
guys back to you thank you Maurice and I
tell you I'm just looking over one of
the things I always had trouble with I
don't know if you ever had this problem
yourself Alejandro is I worked with
Victor kchoi during his world
championship match cycle of 1980 1981
and whenever we played one another it
was always awkward you didn't you didn't
feel good playing against somebody that
you work closely with and I'm looking at
this a match up between Ray Robson and
Alex onuk and I'm wondering how they're
dealing with this pressure because Alex
was Ray's coach well Alex was race coach
but that was when he was very young you
have to understand that players actually
mature and it's definite that Ray Robson
is a different player than when he was
playing Alex onuk and he was quite young
speaking of young players we also have
an interesting tidbit on our youngest
participant Annie
Wang so Annie Wang she's only 12 years
old seventh grader wow impressive and
you were telling me a little bit about
why she got into chess and what her
goals were yeah she came in as a
5-year-old and her father plays chess
but what was really remarkable about
Annie is she became the first women's
Master at the youngest age she actually
uh broke the record set by Arena Crush
that had been a longstanding record for
12 years even older than Annie herself
and then suddenly only in the last year
last month pardon me was Annie's record
broken yet by another young lady wow
it's amazing how the youth is coming up
with such brilliant chust and we see
that even though yesterday's games were
so Topsy Turvy some of the cleanest
games were actually played by the young
participants in the US Women's
Championship I was amazed by their level
and their resistance none of them seemed
nervous all of them seemed focused and
ready to play and these two players
Jennifer and Annie 12 years old and 13
years old I'm just like I'm amazed I
mean two youngest players in the
tournament uh playing and they actually
make Sam Sean look ancient by compers
and it's amazing it's amazing women's
game is definitely getting stronger and
it's getting better and more interesting
so we're delighted to have these two
young competitors playing in their first
US championships definitely not the last
we're going to see many many many more
years right they're very ambitious girls
and just talking to them you can see
that there's a passion for chess I've
actually had the pleasure of working
with a couple of them in chess camps oh
really much when they were a little bit
younger so you're
responsible well not I would not say
that that be taking way too much credit
but it's nice to be able to work with
some of the youth and be just look at
how they approach CH sometimes all this
rigid ideas that we have out of Chess
and we think it's going to be like this
they come up with this new blood this
new way of thinking and it's so nice to
see yeah now turning to the open section
again I'm looking I I think we share the
same view that Hikaru
Nakamura and varac Cobian that's really
going to be a key matchup uh in this
round two your overall thoughts what do
you think uh first of all are we going
to see for the sixth time a French
defense well I really doubt it the
reason that we saw a lot of French
defenses in the Nakamura akobian matches
was that akobian was exclusively a
French player for many many years and
although there's nothing wrong with
playing the French it's actually a very
decent opening and it's doing well at
the top level right now it seems that
akobian is more interested in
diversifying and be able to surprise his
opponents more often right there's two
ways of looking at it right now either
he will surprise go for a caroan or an
E4 E5 or he will surprise surprise and
go back to his French all right so it
might be possible that we see uh not an
E4 opening and that's actually what I'm
going to expect from hikaro that he
doesn't start with E4 uhuh an English or
queen Pawn uh for hikaro although to be
fair with hikaro it really depends on
his mood sometimes you can come throw
out one B3 throw out one G3 fianchetto
on the first move and uh just go for
whatever type of game he uh wants uh
another key matchup for me is just these
Junior players I think of them as the
danger Squad is uh Kaden tro and da
nitzki both of those players
unfortunately lost their first round
game but I see this matchup as being a
matchup of future US Champions I mean
these guys are so young
they're going to be in this tournament
for the next decade if they remain uh
passionate about Chess and uh
continue whoops I think we just lost
something there but we are seeing one
Knight F3 Maurice we'll throw it to you
what do you think about the start of
round two well I think what's
interesting for me is what you said yes
the youth movement in American chess you
look at this is first of all the
youngest the youngest field that's ever
played
in US history it's just incredible
you're looking at babies playing chess I
mean babies yeah but you it's like I say
petting a pet shark you know you know
it's like really you don't want to put
your hand in there because you might get
bitten these young people know how to
play here we have the veteran of the
competition someone by the way people
are somewhat ignoring gakamsky he's not
being talked about too much remember
he's one of the last three championships
this guy is tough but we have two stars
playing in the tournament who are higher
rated than him at the moment and he's
got something to prove against the
youngster in the competition Sam Sean
and then these two youngsters Kon tro
and Daniel nitzki I mean like you said
yes five years from now we're going to
be hailing these youngsters as probably
two of the favorites in the competition
as they begin to emerge with their
talent they are fearless they fight they
want to win games Daniel was disgusted
at himself yesterday for not drawing the
game at least against Wesley so so
expect him to play a fighting game today
I think you're going to see fireworks on
the board here in round
two thank you Maurice
and you were wrong we have a French
defense on Board number one uh E4 was in
fact what uh Hikaru uh began the game
with French defense I was I was fallen
for it Alejandro I was I was compelled
by what you were saying
E5 uh caroan possibilities but remaining
true to his first first love the French
defense uh is varac Cobian Knight C3 an
invitation to complications from the
winner were is uh inviting VAR to play
Bishop B4 and as we know these lines if
you will Knight E7 or C5 can get very
sharp very early but uh V ducked away
from this line and instead he played the
Rubenstein variation and quiet he gives
up a little bit of space but it's very
very solid uh Knight takes E4 Knight D7
Knight F3 and VAR is thinking um Knight
F6 is the most common move by far
although there's something actually even
to be said for Bishop E7 A variation I
championed at one moment but after
knight uh F6 Bishop D3 we get I don't
know variation like this I think that
this line of play by the way was
popularized most by uh George gorg Meyer
he was doing very very well uh on the
black side of these lines and vs
thinking over uh his move uh Knight F6
so early but it's actually just a little
bit of a surprise at least for me I have
played VAR in the past a few times and
I've always had this uncomfortable
decision of playing E4 or D4 against him
because his repertoire is so solid right
but I don't remember him playing a
Rubenstein variation of the French I
thought he was more of a knight F6
classical a classical line and actually
pardon me now that you mention it you're
absolutely right he has been he's been
really true to steinet uh or classical
and you get uh these days it seems by
the way that for the French defense
players most of them are playing the
classical they're shying away from the
winter War they don't like giving up
their Bishops and uh in particular I've
seen wonderful creative player Alexander
morvich playing on the black side of the
classical a move I never considered when
I was playing the French defense this
move V7 B6 uh just keeping uh the pawn
on C5 intact so that you don't give up
the D4 Square I used in the days that I
was playing everybody was playing this
very intriguing ending that went like
this and
if VAR had played this line I would have
uh fully understood his reasoning for it
when you're playing against Hikaru I
think it's a very good idea just to
trade a lot of pieces early try to bore
him to death a little bit well on the
other hand I don't think if it's a good
idea to give hikaro a slight Advantage I
mean this is considered to be slightly
favorable for white just a little bit
Pleasant yes and the main lines of the
classical have gotten extremely
theoretical and extremely sharp right
now we're seeing a lot of early Queen B6
variations after taking on d4h and it's
led to very theoretical games there was
a very interesting series of games by
akstein in Norway last year where he
actually held his own Against the World
Elite right in an incredibly sharp
incredibly theoretical battle um since
it's not relevant anymore exactly it's I
actually prepared this line against gak
kamsky for last year right I played the
French against kamsky and he played the
advanced which is something that I
thought he might play but I didn't think
was going to be the main line I thought
he would play into this variation have
long theoretical variation prepared
against it and and am I right in
thinking that also Hikaru has played
this line as black himself this very
long variation of Queen H4 check
against against Simon Ain and Cy yeah
okay it's uh it's one of the most
theoretical battles of chest right now
mhm probably the Barra is still out
there but it looks very very sharp and
very risky for black so we'll see in a
couple of years what they determine the
real result of the variation is yeah as
Theory settles uh and let's see if we
pardon me let me just get an update on
uh the first table for a moment just a
second where are we there we have it
okay so let's go back so after few
minutes thought alcane Knight F6 as
expected and we're getting
still heavy the theoretical variation um
still lot of theory has developed from
this point Queen C7 I've always kind of
thought as the main move here I'm sure
there are other choices but that has
always struck me as the main move let's
move around the board uh around the
tournament uh for a bit and go to our
second board where our pre-tournament
favorite as well as Hikaru Wesley so
uh Sam opened E4 and as we were talking
before we came on air their first game
that theyve there this is only their
second uh meeting in classical chess
their first meeting uh was in Edmonton
last year and uh Wesley won with black
in a Beno Gambit defense that you've
championed and even didn't done a DVD
about you said Sam didn't know what he
was doing he lost the game and uh he
switched to E4 okay so Wesley
uh he can play a lot of defenses
including uh Sicilian naidorf today he
has chosen to the Berlin It's actually
an interesting choice because I remember
that he played a brilliant game against
ivanchuk in V with a knight sacrifice on
G2 he had analyzed basically everything
up to a draw including the blunder that
Ivan played that suddenly changed the
evaluation of the position from equal to
waiting for black and he knew exactly
what to do against it
and it's just such a mark of such a
strong player where he's able to play in
any variation with such theoretical
depth he's not afraid of going into a
Berlin endgame and Shanklin he's having
none of that right uh on the other hand
if my opponents were all play uh D2 D3
against me I think E5 is probably the
best defense out there uh D2 D3 white
loses something that uh of an open in
edge with this move however like you say
the Berlin ending hasn't been very good
for white in uh the practice that we've
been seeing in the last 10 15 years
Bishop C5 C2 C3 all of these moves are
well-known theoretical moves um it just
hits me that you were saying that the
Berlin defense 105 years it's been 15
years actually since Kik used it so
successfully against Kasparov in their
world championship match and that
actually reminds me that by the time
that you know karnick was using this
powerful idea some of the competitors of
this tournament were not yet
born that makes me feel so old thank you
very much for sharing that one alandro
now on the other hand in the world
championship match between uh Magnus
Carlson and uh vishy Anand um we've seen
um this particular position Knight D2
I'm trying to think was it uh Bishop
takes C6 there was some line with a D4
but okay Knight D2 was Sam's Choice A7
A6 putting the question to the
bishop uh Sam kept his Bishop with
Bishop A4 Bishop A7 uh this stepping
back uh very prophylactic uh move um the
idea is that it's C at at a certain
moment white is going to Aspire for the
central push Central Advance D3 D4 and
black preemptively moves his Bishop uh
to get out of that Tempo and to use an
idea we mentioned Vladimir kik's name
Vladimir kramnick likes this idea of
playing Knight E7 to G6 very quickly and
uh Bishop A7 is a kind of a precursor uh
to a night maneuver let's see how the
game continued a 3 very common move in
the um Spanish torture uh play H2 H3 not
only just getting um stopping any Bishop
G4 Knight G4 ideas many times this
Knight on F3 either moves to H2 or F H4
and makes room for the queen on F3 so H3
very common move 97 there we go we're
going to have a very slow very
positional game I don't expect any
virent attacks in this kind of positions
it'll be a little bit more quiet I think
Wesley's is okay with this kind of
positions being played he has very good
Mastery of the Spanish type of positions
so we'll be keeping an eye on it but
maybe we should look at one of the US
Women's games absolutely let's switch it
over I just before we leave this game I
just note that uh Wesley's last move C7
C5 that catches me a little bit of a
surprise because I wouldn't have been so
pleased about blocking my own Bishop on
A7 but that was Wesley's Choice let's go
down to the ladies games and see what we
have okay Beno Gambit we do have a Beno
Gambit on board which is uh one of my
specialties I guess in chess MH and uh I
already noticed that a
Pera is not familiar at all with this
variation or if she is she is just
playing it wrong right there are certain
details in this position that are
important to note and immediately being
a bank player it strikes me that there's
a couple of things wrong the first and
most important is that the bishop should
be on E2 and not on D3 right and the
other is that she's allowing in this
move to move Bishop
G4 which is a very strong idea since
well for two reasons first the dark
squares are a huge deal in this kind of
positions the domination of the dark
squares is what gives black her
counterplay and even more importantly
than that the bishop on C8 doesn't have
a good square right if you remove G4 the
ability to trade the bishop where does
this bishop go it's not so clear it's
actually the worst piece by far so you
were saying that basically in this
position White made the decision of
castling and that's wholly wrong and you
would have had advised her to have
played H2 H3 keeping saying to Black you
got to keep your Bishop on C8 where it's
doing nothing and um stopping Bishop G4
actually not so much the problem with H3
is that although it does allow it does
disallow Bishop G4 it that's the only
thing it does we're going to go with a
multi-purpose move we can play the move
Knight D2 okay we remove ourselves from
the pin therefore Bishop G4 can always
be met with F3 or simply moving the
queen away which is even more powerful
as the bishop doesn't feel comfortable G
it's not doing anything and more
importantly the Knight goes to D2 to the
very powerful Square Knight to C4 block
the pawn on C5 attacking the queen
controlling E5 it's White's best piece
got it very very sensible uh I don't
know if we are going to see Bishop G4
just a second let me just check to see
uh Black's considering our options again
let's continue our look around the
boards uh you mentioned Anna sheric at
the at the top of the show having won
her first game very fortunately uh
playing against uh
Katarina let's see where did this come
from so this is a Catalan definitely a
Catalan it's just a little strange
Bishop G2 early Bishop D7 in line it's
not so common but it's got some ideas
personally I don't believe in it but
it's a nice surprise weapon and it's not
so easy to refute over the board okay I
do like the way that shich is playing it
with a
quick5 very very attractive move after
all you do open up the Catalan Bishop
okay Bishop C6 basically challenging
white to capture the bishop which he did
and then E3 which is an important move
to sustain that pawn on D4 mhm and
White's not so worried about taking on
C4 immediately okay she will try to do
So eventually but the way that them s
have played this is it's quite
interesting aggressive Queen D7 Castle
on Long
Castle now black is aspiring uh because
she has a slight lead in development
black is aspiring to get in the move E6
E5 to kind of open up the position uh
black doesn't want to sit around and
wait for white to play moves like Knight
D2 Knight takes C4 and recover her Pawn
with a nice position thanks to the two
Bishops well we saw the power of the two
Bishops yesterday I mean immediately the
game between Ray
Robson just shows us how powerful two
Bishops are and there's no way nsoa is
going to sit back and actually you know
take the two Bishops she's going to
fight against them as quickly as
possible and I think we actually have
some footage from the opening ceremony
held at the St Louis Art Museum from
Terry Schaefer
okay
okay I guess we have some technical
problems there I wanted to bring up the
game between Arena crush and Victoria KN
and I see that we have a Gingy Indian if
the Beno Gambit was my specialty I'm
going to defer this game entirely to you
okay well there you go uh a shout out of
course to dear friend Roman gingi hush
villy a legendary chess grandm he came
up with a very intriguing idea that we
now call the Jin Indian uh basically
black fianchetto her Bishop early in the
game Knight C3 strikes out with C5 in
order to open up the dark
Square uh long
diagonal white understandably advances
the pawn and then suddenly bang very
surprising move black has invested so
much time fanh shadowing the bishop and
then suddenly and very surprisingly uh
trades off trading it I would call
sacrificing it sacrificing it uh in
order to rupture uh double Pond uh
double up white CA pawns and then this
very important move that characterizes
uh the Jin Indian is F7 F5 and what
black aspires to do is to bring this
Knight and keep an eye on this E4 square
and challenge White and say okay you've
won the dark Square Bishop on C1 but how
good is it now in this position the most
theoretical move by far is G2
G4 and many many top Grandmaster games
with this move G4 many games you're
being overly modest here I mean there
was a very famous game here no from the
world team
championship wasn't it in this structure
exactly that you beat
madarin yes
then I actually went E4 that was you
went E4 in this position well not in
this exact position uh because he had
his Bishop on f8 and his Pawn on G7 he
went Knight F6 I went oh he went even
more ambitious well yeah just to um show
what my game with Mii and dar off what
that was was I was white D4
C5 D5 F5 ah so he just was trying to do
this C5 F5 thing much sooner right ah he
got punished for it and that was where I
went E4 and so forth and so on okay so
in this game what we have seen thus far
is after F5 F3 and I really don't like
this move by uh the defending and the
champion Arena crush and a big big
favorite to win the event F2 F3 that
just frankly that simply looks wrong a
very common idea for black in
disposition is to go Queen Queen A5
Queen C2 D7 D6 and what black wants to
do is Swing her
Knight Knight D7 followed by Knight E5
and if you think about it if white ever
goes E4 and black trades on e4 with the
pawn and black sticks her Knight on E5
black simply has an excellent game so uh
I'm sure uh for arena uh the Gin Indian
is not a surprised she's seen it Lots in
her career she's very very experienced
player and for her to come up with this
move F2
F3 H it's a little strange we'll have to
keep an eye on it definitely we'll go
back to the opening ceremony with Terry
Schaefer okay Tuesday night they kicked
off the US chess championships and US
Women's chess championships of 2015 at
the St Louis Art Museum with an opening
ceremony where the players did their
choosing of lots so let's take a sneak
peek of the Opening
[Music]
Ceremonies certainly want to thank uh
Jee Hoffman and the US Chess Federation
for um bringing this to St Louis again
and uh the chess club for doing a great
job year in and year out and finally I
want to thank Rex and Genie singfield
for what they've done to make St Louis
the chess capital of the United States
of America enjoy your visit and good
luck to
[Music]
everyone number
one
[Music]
a wonderful opening ceremony by the way
and I really enjoyed a lot of the
speeches the inductee especially of
Alexander shabalov that was a very
emotional nice speech by shaba and a
shout out to him I can't think of any
more deserving player to get into the
World Chess Hall of Fame nice opening
ceremony what an amazing opening
ceremony and of course shabala one of
the greatest players that I have had the
pleasure of meeting let alone playing
and you know it was nice for us the
opening ceremony but for the players
it's just absolutely nerve-wracking it's
where you pick out these numbers which
seem so meaningless but they determine
exactly who you play in what order and
more importantly what color what color
yes and uh I just found this very
intriguing that the two youngest players
in the vent are playing one of the
oldest and most theoretically sharp
variations in modern chess and I got a
throw this to to Maurice because uh A7
A5 Maurice what's up with
that well it just shows you how
dangerous they are these kids are booked
up don't think you're going to sit down
with one of these young ladies and just
wheel out some moves because they will
be prepared and we see this line uh in
the slob a great variation Champion by
everybody you've se nakamori you seen
aronian morvich konnik all the top guns
have dabbled at some point in this
variation and we see this position here
where white is pinning this Knight to
the queen of course there's tension and
this ability to take here and so black
decides to play G5 I mean not a move you
see every day but nowadays it does look
like you see these kind of moves every
day G5 and now the move ignoring the
attack on the bishop because she doesn't
want to trade move Knight E3 attacking
that bishop and now G takes F4 Knight
takes on F5 and castles Queen side of
course an attack on The Queen Is
potentially there with some Discovery so
the the queen moved out of the way Queen
C2 and now Knight to C5 and in this
position white
castled and now black play a move that's
probably not the most popular move A5
championed by none other than yeni Bev
it's been seen four times in the
database and all four times black lost
so it's kind of interesting to see that
young Jennifer has decided to play this
particular line maybe she has some new
wrinkle that she's going to try here
she's been playing very quickly so it's
not as though she just made the move up
she's very clear on the fact that she
wants to play this way so that move is
on the board I'd like to also point out
another fiery game between anovich our
game of the round AN iserovich and
Karina noova and here we have H5 also
opposite side castling H5 going for the
direct attack so Fighting Chess already
happening on the women's side guys thank
you Maurice whoa uh I didn't expect this
H5 by uh Kate and we I thought she was
going to play for E6 6 E5 let's just see
when we had left it I think we had left
it around these parts after castles
Queen
A5 it looks very logical you threaten
the pawn on C4 as well as threatening
the pawn on A7 in case that the Knight
on C6 is removed of course already under
pressure from the G2 Bishop mhm okay
fair enough then came Knight D5 to stop
any ideas that white might have been
dreaming about including Bishop takes C6
Anna said uh let me recapture my Pawn
fair enough Queen takes C4 and H5 right
away none of the E6 E5 that I thought
black might Aspire for H5 right away now
Karina explains so quickly that you have
to assume this is still well within her
preparation exactly she has 1 hour and
32 minutes left when she started with an
hour and 30 minutes this is of course
because of the increment they get every
move they get 30 seconds at it every
time they play a move which means that
she's thought less than 30 seconds per
move exactly at this point I would like
to think that she's inside preparation
even though I don't like this kind of
plants you're your your dubious of uh
Black's attack is uh hitting the mark
especially this bishop on G2 such a
wonderful defender of White's King uh
black could invest a lot of time on the
kingside attack and actually come out
empty-handed just losing time in me the
most about her attack is that she
already gave up her light squired Bishop
which means who is going to be slaying
this Dragon you know this kind of dragon
type structure you always have Excalibur
you guys have this bishop coming in and
killing the defender but how do you do
it here okay you open up the H file you
put your pieces all the way on H6 on h8
and then and then what do you do and
then it might not just be checkmate at
all all right let's continue our uh our
uh tracking around the boards um and I'm
going to go back for a moment to the
Victoria knee Arena Crush game because
once again I'm questioning uh most
especially move six by both players I
don't like this move F3 by Arena and I
am dubious about this move E7 E5 in fact
yeah well yes I like it you like it okay
good I like it from this point of view
right okay shoot white has the pair of
Bishop yes and she wants to make them
incredibly powerful yes let's lock the
game up fair enough um I think in thein
Indian I'm I'm more used to Black
wanting to put a knight on E5 uh I I
just see that in so many uh variations
that to occupy the the square E5 with a
pawn it strikes me as a little bit off
okay it's not bad it's not bad that I'm
just saying that it doesn't for me uh
fit the spirit of the opening yeah
there's another reason I like this move
and it comes from a tactical perspective
sure make a move make a move okay I will
indeed make a move I will play a move
let's say uh you had mentioned that I
wanted to um open up the position
because I have the two Bishops I'll play
E4 but you can't I can it's legal
seriously well it's legal but that's the
extent of it takes Knight H3 so what I'm
trying to do is induce black to capture
on F3 I want to recapture with my queen
and I want to try to use the two Bishops
by blowing open the position um whether
it's sufficient compensation I do agree
I am sacrificing a pawn no question
about it but I do have ideas that maybe
on a very good day I can bring my Bishop
to this square and again on very good
days I could go Bishop D3 and castles
obviously uh I'm making a lot of moves
for myself I'm not letting you get in
any developing moves yourself but I
think in a sense this is what white has
to do she's got to open up the position
she's and if it means taking risk so be
it but that's what I like about the move
E5 is so strategically sound in some
ways that it's forcing white to look for
Pawn sacrifices already to be
provocative yeah because if she doesn't
she's going to fall into a bad position
a bad structure with bad B so it's going
to be really easy for black to play in
so you have to play E4 you have to
sacrifice a pawn right do you want to do
it no too
bad sometimes you're forced to make
risky decisions I agree alandre Maurice
your thoughts well fascinating enough y
the computer agrees with you E4 is a
great move it's a nice move E4 and on
top of it after the capture on e4 it's
saying yeah we're sacking the pawn so
strategically this is consistent your
idea Knight H3 is one move it even
thinks Queen C2 is fine expecting you to
take back on F3 where Knight Will
capture back and it's a pawn down but so
what the two Bishops are going to have
some influence on the position so that's
a definite idea that could be played
here there's another game that I'd like
to pay attention to where we just I just
saw an interesting exchange which I
thought was weird and uh for for a
second when I saw it well I still think
it's weird right in this position the
game between the youngest player in a
competition on the men side Samuel in
the open section Samuel seon against
gakamsky and here we see a typical
looking Ru Lopez position no problem you
expect some natural moves here and SE
and Sam played Bishop takes on C5 and
I'm like really what is that about D
takes C5 it seems like you're giving up
a bishop the bishop can blockage your
Pawn easily on the Square and Knight F1
even more befuddling to my eyes and then
when I asked the computer what do you
think about this variation and it said
yeah that's what I would have played
both Bishop C5 and Knight back to F1 so
I'm confused clearly I'm not in the age
of computer chess because I'm confused
by that trade I'd love to know your
thoughts on that y because uh it seems
like it's a new generation playing chess
got sure we'll jump right into that let
me just go to that game uh again I'll
just bring out the game between God hsky
and Sam Sean I do believe this was a
Brer uh Spanish let's just make sure of
that and indeed so far so good this is
all standard uh theoretical work Knight
B8 looks strange but this is important
repositioning of the Knight so that the
bishop on B7 can put pressure on the E4
pawn and the Knight on D7 is much more
flexible than the C6 Square so all of
this is very
standard and at one time uh this move C5
was all the rage you go back to the 50s
and 60s in the Soviet School of Chess uh
you would see a lot of the Soviet
championships uh featuring this position
and
later they thought that this
position was just fine for black and the
move Bishop takes C5 was frowned upon
they say don't play the move Bishop
takes C5 because black will get a very
good blockading Bishop on the D6 square
but there was a recent game of d D lren
Grandmaster ding lren who was white who
absolutely crushed his opponent with
this bishop takes C5 which the Soviet
authorities had said don't do and uh the
idea was that what ding ended up doing
was getting a knight on E3 Queen on C2
he played this ABAB and B2 B3 and he
broke through magnificently on both
sides of the board so Bishop takes C5 is
a latest wrinkle in a decades old uh
Brer defense actually I know this from a
more theoretical perspective uh I had
this position on my preparation board
really when I was playing kamsky for the
Armageddon in the 2013 us Championship
cuz you knew he play that got kamsky
played the correct yeah so I thought
about playing this position and I knew
that there's a couple of ideas there's
also an interesting game I want to say
it's VanCamp and Lami where white goes
for G4 and the idea of G4 is so done to
prevent F5 at some point from black so
you rest restrict black on the king side
okay don't let them play anything if
they become a little too crazy on the
queen side you can break on the king
side under correct circumstances okay
and then you do exactly what the dingly
r plan was of playing Rook A3 Rook uh e
A1 right then you break on B3 at the
correct point you put the Knight on E3
Bishop D1 to E2 and the question here
for black is where's your counter play
exactly so I have seen this and it's
become not exactly in Vogue but the idea
is that white has some kind of pressure
and some kind of ideas to play for a win
and black has absolutely nothing but to
wait that doesn't sound very attractive
for the second player does it so now I
can understand why he wanted to prepare
for he just wanted to uh keep him under
wraps uh young s SE on uh uh taking
advantage maybe a bit do you you think
that God has as theoretically prepared
these days as he was when he was playing
for the world championship well um we're
about to find out I guess we're about to
find out I suppose I think it's a good
time to take a small quick break okay
and we'll be right back with you
guys
[Music]
hi I'm Mike maeni I've been part of some
great clubs and now I'm part of
another the chess club in Scholastic
Center of St Louis right here in the
chess capital of the us our
world-renowned Center is dedicated to
teaching playing and promoting the sport
because chess has been proven to enhance
academic performance our Scholastic
outreach program now works with over a
100 Schools so whether you've played for
years or never before come experience
all that chess has to
offer
2014 was a great year for chess chess 24
brought you live interactive broadcasts
from Top tournaments a Play Zone where
you can take on opponents from all
around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your Chess By solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos chess 24 on mobiles
and tablets most features are free but
limited for registered members chess 24
is offering a special premium membership
for just $999 per month or $99 per year
see you at chess24.com
Queen H5 well we have some interesting
games here and Maurice actually has
fascinating one for us all right well
you can always expect it on the women's
side they play some enterprising chess
we saw the game with the youngsters
playing that wild classical variation we
also saw an iserovich and Karina mova
going at it and matter of fact I'll just
jump to that board really quickly we saw
opposite side castling when we left it
she had just played the move H5 in the
position and now after Bishop to D2 H4
definitely going for her piece of the
action in our Rook C1 so we see opposite
side castling a pawn storm beginning
here expect to see the move B4 and B5
coming down quite soon on this side as
well in another game on the women's side
one of the pre-tournament favorites
tatev abrahamyan she is playing against
Alysa Melina she played a French defense
and we could go over the moves just a
bit here Alyssa who is a lawyer Now by
trade she doesn't like to venture into
too many wild main lines and so in this
line here she decided just to trade
that doesn't mean she's not aggressive
she's a wild attacking player and here
she went after the two Bishops quite
quickly and now if the Knight G E7 what
did she do a move you say don't do these
kind of moves kids Queen H5 I'm put by
Queen out there uh could you please
Castle well no it's not going to happen
Bishop E6 and now Rook B1 attacking a PA
after B6 Knight F3 Queen to D7 now
another attacking move Knight to G5
eyeballing this side of the board and
what happens next cast Queen side so in
the men's side that is in the open
section Castle's King side has happened
just about every board on the lady's
side half the games have the King on the
opposite side of the board very
aggressive chess and you can see there
Alyssa Melina who's definitely one who
likes to attack she doesn't like any
endgame she doesn't want to trade all
pieces and she is showing that she's
intense there and there is tatev looking
to see what to do in this position she
did not take the pawn which would have
been a horrible blunder to capture uh
this Pawn this early because of this
tiny pin you might lose a piece well you
would so instead she took on E6 here and
we have this position now on the board
uh I actually no she traded first and
Bishop to E3 of course she could have
played Queen E2 and played that position
but as I said she doesn't like ingame so
you could have suspected she was not
going to do that so now we have a very
unbalanced position opposite side
castling will happen after castles the
two Bishops against the two knights the
unusual Pawn
distribution definitely all seeds for a
fighting game as we come to expect
always on the ladies side of the
Championships guys yeser explain to me
you're you're a very classical player
right tell me a little bit more about
what you feel having those two knights
against that horrible Pawn structure or
do you prefer the
Bishops and in the uh in the abrahamian
game yeah
that I was was hoping you wouldn't
ask let's let's let's bring that up
um I must confess uh I feel that the
bishop versus knight and the two Knights
versus two Bishops um positions are some
of the most awkward
um challenges uh challenging positions
classically speaking I like the two
Bishops okay however when a player
structure is specifically in this case
the this white structure is kind of uh
broken on the queen side and the if the
knights get good squares suddenly you
know I like the knights um at this
precise moment um I think that also the
king the importance of uh King shelter
is a key factor in the game so in other
words if White
Castle uh short and her King is safer
than Black's King that that's also a
kind of a plus it's not just about
Knights and Bishops but the king safety
becomes a key element at the moment I'm
just going to bail out with that lousy I
see a balance position kind of thing
slightly favoring white but not that
much all right well speaking of opposite
Castle positions we have apparently a
very interesting game and this is not
from the US Women's
rce yes it looks like I spoke too soon
because on the men on the on the other
side of the championship I keep calling
it men's and and women's in fact it's
the Open Championship uh that the men
are playing and ladies are allowed to
play in that if they qualify for the
event but the game one of the games of
the round undoubtedly between Hikaru
Nakamura the top seed in the competition
number three in the world by the way
guys he is now uh right again up against
that 2800 rating his live rating is 27
99.7 so I think he says round up round
up if he wins today he will definitely
go back above
2800 and uh be in very rarified air and
also if he does pretty just decently in
this tournament gets a few rating points
he will be number two in the world
passing Fabiano Carana for that honor so
a lot to play for for him in this
tournament in this position against
verua niobian who was something to say
about getting rating points he castled
queenside
and vuan castled King's side and now in
this position Nakamura decided to
capture on C5 and all of us waiting for
the natural Bishop sake C5 equal
position uh or or at least some fighting
stuff going on let's see what happens
VAR played B6 sacrificing a pawn looking
to blow open this side of the board and
get his attack going so an exciting game
definitely something to pay attention to
guys and look at nakamura's response
he's almost uh contemptuous like how
dare you play such a move definitely a
fighting game guys of foot on this board
once to watch and now the jackets Come
Off forget all the cool calm attitude
it's time to play some chess right now
it must be difficult playing against
your opponent and with a picture of your
opponent right next to you to remind you
right right I I bing uh we would make a
lot of jokes uh about Gary Kasparov when
during his reign as world champion uh
whenever you saw the jacket coming off
when Gary took off his jacket it meant
okay now he's bearing down and he's
being very serious let's bring up that
board board table number one on uh
second round and we've just seen this
move Dake C5 by hikaro as uh Maurice was
saying the number three ranked player in
the world without a doubt hikaro had
probably calcul calculated pardon me a
line that went Bishop takes C5 Bishop
takes Queen takes
Knight E5 and in his Mind's Eye
undoubtedly hearo thought well I'll get
to throw my pawns on the king side
forwards and Black's pawns on the queen
side are way too slow I've got a nice
comfortable attack I'm going to be a
very happy camper
well VAR threw a spanner in that in that
uh plan by playing this move B7 B6 very
enterprising Pawn sacrifice and one I
heartily approve of even though I love
pawns I mean so who I thought it was
actually a very common idea in this
structure precisely because black wants
to recapture with the pawn exactly
exactly uh black does want to recapture
with the pawn so that he can protect the
square D4 and white doesn't get to use
that square now uh I'm a greedy player I
like being material ahead but I must say
I would really really shy away from
capturing the pawn and opening up that
Rook against my my uh King in a sense uh
the initiative for the next 15 20 moves
is all going to lie with uh black in
this position White's attack on the king
side is going to be much slower than
Black's attack on the queen side this is
not something that uh Hikaru who's noted
for uh uh playing for the initiative
himself is going to play I don't see C
takes B6 uh at all coming up having said
that what is white going to do uh White
uh it's clear that black his intentions
are clear he just wants to open up the
queen site with B take C5 and White's
got to figure out well what plan uh he
would
like if I were white I would probably be
considering Bishop D4 takes Bishop E5
but I'm thinking black is doing fine in
this position and oh pardon me another
move I might consider consider is a move
a you know just to take the D5 Square
under control and after for example C4
recapturing again not the ideal setup my
Bishop on E3 feels definitely feels
misplaced
um hiar is going to have a hard one a
hard time coming up with a decent way of
meeting this he could toss out
C6 perhaps he might do something like C6
Queen takes C6
95 uh again playing for the initiative
um
but I'd be happy if I were black I don't
see any problems here well apparently we
could be speculating all day but we have
seen this position before actually okay
really it's theoretical a theoretical
position and it's been played twice in
top level games the first time we saw
this game was in Anan
vanelli 2006 okay where Anan played
Bishop D4
Bishop David four as I was thinking
about a draw after after a series of
moves I think B takes C5 and not
entirely positive of the continuation
okay but there was an even more recent
example of a very greedy player okay one
whose name is very difficult to
pronounce but I'm going to try Ian
nepi okay and he is one of the top
Russian players playing against another
top Russian uh andrein yes and nepo said
so what took on B6 no way and was
promptly punished okay he he accepted
the gauntlet and he choked on it right
and do you know how the game continued
from this point did he play King
B1 I don't know the only things I could
probably look at this position is of
course King B1 defending the pawn on A2
but also Bishop C4 maybe trying to hold
down the entire Queen side with the
bishop MH both look dangerous for white
to say black uh Black's uh play here
should not be underestimated it's kind
of like a sicilian where black has
gotten in uh D5 and traded off the D
Pawn so that actually this bishop on E7
does a double duty in a sense um it's
prepared in case of an A2 A3 move to
sacrifice itself it's also a great
defender of the king side uh just
holding up F6 and f8 and so that's
that's a very powerful Bishop that is
hidden hidden away I like another
powerful Bishop came into the game
actually and continue with Bishop B7 yes
trying to play Bishop
D5 tra trading off the bishop on C4 yes
Bishop D4 was
played and then
B5 love it of course that pawn
absolutely poison cannot take that pawn
on B5 because of that pawn on A2 that's
not an equal trade at all not so much no
exactly so Bishop B3 continued Bishop D5
and eventually nepi was unable to hold
his Queen sight together already I think
that even though white has an extra Pawn
it's so much more pleasant to play with
black exactly I don't see Hikaru as
willingly uh picking up the defense of
this position at all and I just looking
at the Monitor and Hikaru is really
bearing down now because he has been
surprised and I'm surprised that he's
surprised because after you've got if
you're in the world's top uh 10 you've
got to study the games of of nepo I'm
not going to try to say nothing not
actually but you've got to study his
games because he's a very very uh
important player in the world's uh Elite
and uh this seems to have
caught uh hikaro flat-footed sometimes
what happens is that you look at these
games you got the understanding you got
the ideas but you don't remember exactly
how it happened the details right and I
don't think this is fresh in his memory
considering that we didn't expect a
Rubenstein that is true from mobian we
didn't really expect the setup he's not
as familiar with the structure as he
would be if he just saw it over the
preparation board MH all right let's
move along as uh Hikaru is struggles
with his problems I I'm still intrigued
by our discussion uh about the arena
Crush game so let me bring let me go to
our defending Women's Champion Arena
Crush Where Are You arena there you are
um we've had our discussions about this
move E5 I thought E4
was mandatory I'll just put it that way
Knight H3 is okay H7 H6 Victoria playing
she's trying her best to keep the
position as close as possible
I I'm just guessing that she didn't want
to play for example pardon me I'm
guessing she didn't want to play E7 E6
she might have been concerned that white
would have played Knight G5 to E6 even
at the cost of the pawn I'm not sure she
made proper judgment about that she did
however play the move H6 just
controlling
G5
G3 not a move that I'm a fan of I like
this move very much by the way going
back to this moment instead of the move
G3 if White had played the move D5 D6
with the idea of sacrificing the pawn I
would applaud this move uh more than I
appla I don't think highly of G3 what is
that Bishop going to do whether it's on
G2 or H3 I don't think highly of this
move D6 I think Arena has been outplayed
as
white do you think that maybe G3 has the
idea idea of stopping F4 in C of
E4 more so I'm thinking that Arena wants
to play Bishop F1 to H3 at a certain
time you're right she may have been
concerned that E4 might have been met by
F5 F4
but I wouldn't have I wouldn't have gone
out of my way to prevent black from
playing F4 uh at the moment I can see
very easy play for black I mean black
just wants to play moves like for
example Knight B8 to D7
well and you're not going to believe me
here but Knight to F6 and Knight it's
all theoretical no don't you dare tell
me not so much okay not so much but the
move F3 has been played before
byan
Nei okay so Arena study Meo games
although perhaps not as relevant as the
game was played in 1996 and
Ian wasn't exactly nipple that he is
right now he was just a talented
youngster mhm uh however the game did
continue with this idea of G3 no KN H3
though okay and okay perhaps the game
result is not as relevant as it was a
long time ago but this will be a very
interesting kind of position without
question it will be a good time for us
to take our break and we will be back
with more fascinating games and we have
for you a puzzle up here
okay
[Music]
for
well we are back in the 2015 US Chess
Championship and the 2015 US women's
Chess Championship from St Louis
Missouri America's chess capital and we
have here with you to kick off stuff the
puzzle solution with marce
Ashley
nakor I'm sorry we're having sound
issues all right well we can take a
quick look first at some of the
controversial decisions yes that
happened while we were on break by some
of the players right exactly well I'm
pulled up uh our table number one where
hikaro
Nakamura was given this opportunity to
uh win upon at the cost of uh seeding
his opponent the initiative Hikaru
surprising to for me accepted the offer
took the pawn opening up The Rook on a
eight against the pawn on A2 hikaro
covered his A2 Pawn with the move King
B1 Bishop uh came to C from C8 on this
beautiful long diagonal and inaru
offering to return the pawn with a move
Knight D4 so we uh during our break
Alejandra we've been looking at should
uh black uh pick up the gauntlet accept
the pawn and then just drop back here
with his Bishop we were looking at the
variation C4 Bishop B7 Bishop H6 trying
to take advantage of this G file and
then Knight E8 and we hadn't made heads
or tails when The Puzzle Master I think
is back with us
Maurice well I'm not the puzzle Meister
I was talking badly about our puzzle
Meister because he gave us an easy one
today I know he's going to be upset at
me for saying it's too easy because he
was giving us some hard ones before I
said dude give us a break those problems
are too difficult so I know he's uh he's
going to get us next time around but
this one was by Nakamura when he was a
Youngster in 2004 uh he was against an
opponent zisman and one thing you look
at in this position you see that Bishop
on E8 and you think what what is that
Bishop doing on E8 and it's not doing
much naturally you'd prefer to have the
bishop all the way over here on B7 so
with that in mind with the fact that
Black's pieces are clustered on this
side of the board what did Nakamura do
what does Nakamura always do sacrifice
something take something whatever if
it's greed like he is right now against
akobian or if it's the sacrifice because
he's going to get a winning game well
this game is definitely over after the
capture he played Queen to G4 check you
might have thought it was Knight F6
check those of you who are doing that
kind of created some difficulty for
yourself in that line this is so much
cleaner wherever the King goes it really
doesn't matter this Knight is going to
plunk in all on F6 and the problem is
the mate on the back ring this bishop is
so bad it can't move out the way and any
trade highlights the fact that Black's
pieces are simply too far from the
action you've got to keep some
connection to your king especially when
you're playing against an attacking
Genius Like Karu Nakamura guys well
we're talking about the attacking genius
Karu Nakamura and yet here he is showing
us his versatility he takes a pawn wants
to defend yeah now I have to ask you
yaser do you think he would have done it
was he playing andrein was he playing
neomi was he playing a strong 2700 or do
you think he's just happy with creating
any kind of complications against the
player he feels is lower rated and he
has to
win tough questions uh first of all uh
when you're playing against a lower
rated player in this case varac Kian and
it's tough to think of vovan lower rated
player and a player that you were
supposed to score against uh he wants a
that is to say hikaro wants a position
uh that's um uncompromising that's messy
uh nothing that's boring and static and
so capturing this Pawn on B6 achieves
that goal uh is it the right decision uh
sometimes you know you've got these
boundaries in chess you know you risk in
order to win we saw that yesterday with
Sam Sean he was risking in order to win
he lost a game by overstepping uh the
boundary Hikaru didn't he do that same
thing yesterday yes yes Hikaru uh is
often uh transgressing but of late it
it's sort of like we're seeing a really
improved hikaro I mean he we talked a
little bit about him being one of the I
think there's only like eight or nine or
maybe 10 players who've ever broken the
2800 barrier and he's done that okay two
years ago he was on the outside looking
in you know and now he's on the inside
and he's saying look I'm number three in
the world I'm about to be number two in
the world if I can get a win today and
uh go past uh Fabiano um but the
question is in this exact moment um will
VAR risk capturing this Pawn on G2 not
his only uh choice of course and and
whoops that's not the good move I think
Bishop D5 is our main variation C4
normally speaking you like to uh provoke
your opponent to open up his Pawn Shield
you like uh to encourage your opponent
to play a move like C2 C4 as the pawn on
C4 while it covers the D5 Square it does
expose the King on B1 uh somewhat and
we've been looking at this position I'm
not saying Bishop H6 is the only move
but it certainly looks visually as the
move you like to play Knight E8 although
it's equal material
it's the position can blow up you know
almost like literally at any time it
does look however how black just seems
to be suffering a little bit here his
initiative has been thwarted sowhat it's
white creating the threat would you
really go for this I know that you're a
very greedy player yes I'm a greedy
player for the initiative right I would
never consider taking on G2 I would uh
simply because uh even though the Knight
on E8 appears passive which it is of
course on E8 it also opens up this uh
Bishop on E7 to come to F6 especially
after the move C2 C4 has been played the
bishop on F6 is going to be a very good
defensive bishop and a very good
offensive Bishop I remember there was
this one very beautiful game between
Mickey Adams as white and a naidorf
against uh Gary Kasparov as black and
Gary managed to put his Knight or Bishop
on E7 on F6 and it was terrific it both
defended his King and attacked White's
King on B1 uh these positions where both
players are castled on opposite sides
are our favorite types of positions uh
because they just allow for uh both
players to basically go crazy and to
attack uh madle on the king side well
speaking of crazy games and interesting
attacks well we have some kind of
Counterattack going on the king side
some attack going on the queen side
Maurice tell us more yeah attacking
madly on the king side it felt like you
stole my words yes right at this game
between anovich and Karina enovo we saw
black play the move H5 then the move H4
we'll check this out after she traded on
G3 she played the move F5 you're Wonder
wondering what's going on here after
Knight C3 well don't guess G5 she's
coming to win she's looking at ideas
like F4 eventually and Anna just played
the move Queen to A4 which is sort of a
tepid move in a way in this position but
if you look at it it's clear that black
is looking to rain down on this side
well she doesn't really get anything by
bringing her Queen to H7 and to H2
because the king just moves but she is
looking to crack open that side with
pawns and if she gets just a few moves
she could bring her Bishop out get a
rook in and maybe make hay in that
position another game really fascinating
occurrence on this board between Alisa
mahina and one of the favorites we
mentioned before tat abrahamyan in this
position white played the unusual Rook
fe1
offering the two Rooks for the queen and
this position when you look at it you
can go down a main line here after Queen
takes on E1 Rook takes Rook takes check
Bishop back and now now the move Knight
to E4 is possible and analyzing this
line the engines are saying wait a
minute you can even play Queen takes
here giving away this bishop because of
this Fork attacking both Knight and rook
and now ignoring the rook in the corner
because after King to B7 black is going
to play Knight D2 winning material at
least so it appears but after this move
Knight here King over and now white is
saying after you take I just move over
and win my piece right back the engine
just still saying this is the main line
for black in this position crazy chess
could emerge but a bold move by by
Alyssa that is with the white pieces
sending her opponent into an even deeper
Think Tank tatv has spent a lot of time
getting to this position she's way
behind on the clock in fact Alyssa
started with 1 hour and 20 and 1 hour
and 30 minutes to start the game she is
now at 124 and9 seconds she hasn't even
used six minutes or hasn't lost we
should say since she's getting
increments she hasn't lost six minutes
from her original time while her
opponent's already at 3528 and Counting
after such a controversial move as Rook
F won amazing game uh exploding right
now in the women's championships guys
than you Mar well Yer tell me a little
bit about this you see tff losing her
game yesterday yes do you think brutal
this is basically the reason that she's
an hour behind today well for sure when
you start with with a loss in any event
it's a confidence it's a blow to one's
confidence and what happens is it kind
of you get steamrolled
you once you've lost your confidence
suddenly you're you're you're
double-checking you're reanalyzing
you're your your your calculations you
keep reconfirming and you start burning
a lot of time on your clock and that
produces time trouble which produces
more mistakes so it's like when your
confidence gets broken it really has um
a snowballing type effect now having
said that uh it seems to me that I would
take the two Rooks I would just grab
that Rook on E1 and say thank you very
much I mean I'm the kind of guy that
looks at the position and doesn't think
Rook fu1 was a legal move you just
worried about a backr check I was
looking at it on the corner of my eye I
was like oh there's some kind of relay
error I mean why just blundered
something but no apparently there's some
kind of deep idea strategically with the
pair of Bishops coordinating with the
queen right probably better than I can
understand right tactics there might
work out but that looks like a real real
double-edged move by Alisa that Rook fe1
I wouldn't have played it myself
speaking of double edge games we have so
many in both sections take us a quick
look perhaps at the Kaden Trove game yes
between da and Kaden we haven't seen
that we also haven't seen the game
between Alexander onook and Ray Robson
but let's have a look um here we are M
okay actually wow and only 10 moves
played so far both players playing very
very very slow okay so we have a Queen's
Gambit decline uh Bishop B4 Vienna
Bishop G5 takes on uh C4 E2
E3 I was more familiar with the E4 idea
E2 E4 is uh considered Mainline uh stuff
but E2 E3 I'm not that familiar myself
with it okay uh Daniel said I've taken
your Pawn I'm going to keep it play B7
B5 uh I'm not going to allow Bishop take
C4 what are you going to do about it
Kaden said I'll go Knight
D2 H okay so the move Knight D2 allows
for Knight takes B5 as well as opening
the way for Queen F3 with uh uh e evil
intentions of winning an entire Rook
over there on
A8 Dan says okay C7 C6 covers both
threats I'll protect my Pawn on B5 as
well as neutralize the threat of Queen
F3 now A2 A3 that move actually comes as
a surprise to me these types of
positions were also very familiar with
A2 A4 uh attempting to undermine the
pawn on B5 Kaden said I'll play
A3
uh don't know what to think about that
move at the moment it just it just looks
a little strange Bishop E7 also looks a
little strange the entire Mo game looks
very strange starting from this move
Knight D2 I am familiar with the idea of
e3 sometimes trying to go into this nobo
looking setups but with the bishop on G5
yeah but Knight on D2 yeah it seems so
ambitious yeah the bishop retreats to E7
and tells a little bit about the the
fact that in this position despite the
fact that after Bishop B7 white gives up
his dark sored Bishop it's black that
has the dark Square
weaknesses well the idea there again
when you talk about dark Square
weaknesses is this
C5 uh well D6 I wouldn't sometimes D6
becomes the dark Square weakness when
the knights on D7 right so just for for
example we'll play a move like for for
example Bishop
and this idea that sometimes when the
Knight can can come to E4 either Knight
in this case actually I'm used to seeing
the other KN Knight C3 to E4 to C5 not
necessarily Knight to D2 to E4 to C5 uh
you uh the bishop ends up having uh to
cover uh squares like E5 and C5 now
again with the Knight on D2 that's very
different than the Knight on F3 the
Knight on F3 usually hops to E5 that's
correct so uh also I've seen this uh
really the computers really expanded our
awareness uh to consider a lot of moves
we would have previously just dismissed
out of hand but I have I've seen this
very often that uh players are playing
recapturing on F6 maintaining their
Bishop on E7 and recapturing the pawn on
F6 like you were saying uh to in order
to butus let me just do that if I can uh
butress some control of dark squares now
of course you're doubling the pawns but
let's just see what H what what has
happened after Bishop takes F6 Bishop
takes F6 A4 uh da to play now normally
speaking black would like to maintain
his Pawn on B5 with a move on like A6 in
this case it's simply not possible
because White can take advantage of the
pin on the a file if Dan wants to
maintain his Pawn on B5 he may have to
go for a line like Queen B6 well it's
going to be an interesting development
both players spending so much time to
get to this position both of them
already under an hour with only 10 moves
played they're both playing it very
slowly so this has not been home
preparation by either player not by any
means and we have new developments in a
very interesting position we're going
back to probably what's going to be the
game of the day okay car Nakamura
playing against voban marce
Ashley thanks guys I was looking at that
position that you guys were analyzing
and it is first of all it looked like a
atypical Nakamura position him stealing
a pawn looking to defend and now in one
line it's very much looking like a
Nakamura type position where he is
sacrificing in order to blow the guy's
head off take a look at this position
he's just played the move Knight to D4 a
deep centralizing move this Knight is
very flexible could land on B5 and you
start to feel like Black's attack is not
going anywhere if White's pieces can be
that much better centralized with easy
access to the queen side well let's just
look at the greed variation Bishop takes
on G2 Rook H D1 maybe bishop D5 it's not
going to matter after C4 the bishop
drops back and white black might say I
got a pawn back if you try for anything
here with Bishop H6 Knight to E8 um I'm
holding that side well well you're not
because Bishop takes on G7 blowing the
position open Knight takes and now
simply Queen H5 a little tiny M threat
deal with that one what can you do
suddenly there's nothing to do it's mate
on 87 the Knight is pinned F5 simply
runs into a sacrifice with Rook takes
King takes give me that and King's under
attack Queen's under attack so Knight D4
is saying don't touch my Pawn or else so
Nakamura putting it back on his opponent
who maybe thought he had the attack and
he's seeing there's a reason why this
guy's number three in the world guys
nice variation thank you Maurice that
certainly clears the cobwebs doesn't it
uh um Bishop takes G7 uh is a killer
tactical blow uh having said that if you
can't play uh Bishop takes G2 I'm
looking at table one I'm thinking that
VAR may decide like white has just
centralized his Knight I should
centralize my knight too the idea again
is I think that this bishop does belong
on the F6 square and with Knight D5
obviously if I can win the two Bishops
I'll have compensation for a long while
with Knight takes E3 so uh VAR may be
considering his choice if Bishop takes
G2 and maybe like me Overlook you know
decisive blow Bishop takes G7
but without Bishop takes G2 I would uh
favor the move Knight
D5 let's look at some games we haven't
seen and uh by the way just going to
table number two with Wesley
so uh the last move was D4 D5 C5 C4 very
very block closed positions uh closed
position this bishop on B7 is not
looking very uh promising takes takes
and B2
B3 Queen C7
and uh Sam to play I like I like uh
White's space uh here I I favor white
well I'm going to compare and contrast
this position this looks like a very
typical Spanish situation indeed so but
don't you just feel like Black's up a
bunch of Tempe he got over a chor or
something exactly
the bishop is not a goodie I'll proba
put it back on C what conerns me is tell
me more you're an expert situations you
know I already got my knight to G6 right
that's a big deal actually that you're
right it does feel like black has a has
gained a certain Tempe I would say uh
over standard but still uh no question
black has the F4 square but white to his
credit also has the F5 Square so and the
immortal words of Bobby fiser to get
squares you got to give them and at the
moment uh C3 could be um vulnerable so
uh I'll borrow a a page from Jennifer
shahadi she loves the Rover Rook up and
over she calls it so Rover could come up
rook E3 with ideas like Knight F5 but I
hear you loud and clear uh that black
will probably simply drop back with his
Bishop to cover the F5 square
and maybe maybe Wesley will be satisfied
with the outcome I still I still do
prefer Sam's position I like space
always have let's continue our look
around uh this is a game again uh I
always I always found it difficult to
play against players that I had worked
with professionally as a trainer uh Ray
Robson versus Al uh onuk and you had
mentioned well they they prepared
together years ago when Ray is not Ray
Ray matured got better and taller and
taller and it was an anti-
Marshal uh
Spanish the players seem to have been
playing pretty rapidly up to this Parts
D4 some long Thinking by Alex he played
Bishop F6 Queen
D3 and uh first impressions
this Knight on A5 really bad you got to
get that Knight back into the game and
that's why Alex played the move C7 C6 um
very positional a little slow and we're
seeing that the players are taking their
time Ray Robson with this usual I want
to be in time troubled mood already
using a lot of time straight out of the
opening we're going to go for a small
clip with Teran schaer on improving your
brain while playing
chess
we had a problem small technical detail
small technical problem there but okay
that allows us to go into more detail on
the Spanish we actually have a lot of
Spanish structures today we're look at
the Robson against honest game we look
at the Shanklin against so key match
right and well let's not forget about a
very important game today Samuel Sean
against gakamsky exactly well I'm just
looking at this uh game of rays and I'm
not exactly sure what white should do
after this move C7 C6 I'm not
enthusiastic about capturing on C6 and
uh allowing black to reposition his
night back in into the game I don't see
this as a a position that would lead to
an advantage for white unless I could
artificially somehow isolate it this
Pawn on uh B4 by doing something a
little bit
unorthodox like this I'm Pawn is also
isolated exactly I mean uh black may end
up uh putting pressure on the D Pawn I
Way D takes C6 was play it in the game
yeah the problem was even though I I'm
shying away from the move d takes C6 I
didn't see a very good alternative I uh
while we were going to go to that um uh
clip that didn't quite happen we'll get
it to you for sure uh I was trying to
analyze the consequences of this one and
I was thinking well gee that pawn on D6
might become more of a liability than an
asset after for example a move like Rook
E6 uh I can't uh simply protect my Pawn
with Rook D1 because I've got to keep an
eye over E5 E4 I always see a lot of
young players and players that are
really trying to improve have a problem
determining whether a pawn is strong or
a pawn is weak and do you think for
example that in this case it would be a
good time to look at development to see
how much support a specific Pawn has
what I want to ask is do you think Ray
robson's Pawn in that position after d
takes E5 D takes E5 D6 is weak mainly
because white hasn't been able to finish
his development in this position
precisely so that that in fact is key
the the the key Point uh D6 would be a
wonderful move if the the the bishop was
somehow on C1 was out and I would be
white would be able to
support uh the advanced Pawn on D6 with
Rook on a D1 and that being behind in
development in fact stops him from being
ambitious uh with this D E5 D D6 ideas
and sometimes it's even just one move
had the Knight been for example on D2 I
can start thinking about playing Knight
E4 defend the pawn wonderful position
for the Knight right but chess is about
one tempo right timing yes exactly
timing is key and Maurice you've got
some insights to share just wanted to
jump back to a game that we saw that
crazy looking move to our eyes the move
Rook f w between Alissa meina and tatv
abrahamyan after Rook f w tatv went into
a modestly deep think and decided to not
capture on E1 instead she played the
move Knight to
E4 going into a bit of a self pin here
and uh we're we're a little surprised by
that so I decided to just play around
with the computer a little bit to see
good variations and it's thinking that
just capturing is a strong move here and
then dropping the queen back to E2
looking at the logic of it White's pawns
have been released from prison now these
pawns are thinking of going up the board
C4 and D5 and black has to be care F the
queen is thinking about nibbling in on
the A6 square if I follow a line King B7
just to stop any checks now Rook e D1
with the threat of D5 and also C4 of
course Knight A5 to stop C4 D5 anyway
and if Queen D6 to attack this Pawn all
the attacking players will say ponm you
can have it if you take it Bishop back
to E3 and this is starting to look like
dark clouds gathering over Black's
position with a pawn headed to C5 the
pieces ready to swing this is the kind
of position Alysa mahina would love to
have especially with the big time Edge
she has on the clock so I'm not sure
about that move 94 TV has to be very
careful in this situation that her
opponent doesn't come up with something
very powerful and send her into a real
Tail Spin having already lost the first
game of the Championships guys wow
interesting strategic ideas I wouldn't
have uh really occurred to me to give up
the two Bishops so willingly and then
just drop back and play for attack in
that position so many unnatural moves
first of all offering two Rooks for a
queen show the two Rooks being better
then declining after a 10-minute think
that quite honestly she couldn't afford
she only has 34 minutes on her clock
going down to 24 minutes plenty of time
until we actually reach move 40 but
already looking a little suspicious and
speaking of suspicious moves okay I I'm
looking at the game Nakamura Kian which
we're going to be looking at a lot today
for sure but this last move yes sir I
actually thought it was one of the major
uh choices for black and I I couldn't
decide between Knight D5 only after he
very reluctantly rejected Bishop takes
G2 I thought Knight D5 was primary move
but I also thought Rook A5 had its
points as well I mean essentially black
has sacrificed a pawn for the open a
file let's try to exploit it by doubling
up so very straightforward idea by black
he wants to bring his Rook here to Rook
f88 play Rook takes A2 and check mate
white brilliantly so I saw this move as
being quite reasonable uh What uh what
did you see Alejandro that made you jump
and say wait a minute what is that move
all about why did you uh reject the move
I don't like the move because I think uh
the idea is to Telegraph you know that
is true you're going to be
it's you're playing Rook uh A5 you're
playing Rook A8 you're hoping I don't
defend my pawn and then everything is is
it's sweet but you know right now I'm
going to play the move Knight B5 which I
think hikaro did play and I'm starting
to think that if you run out of space on
the queen side to put a lot of your
pieces you're suddenly going to be stuck
with just two Rooks attacking on the a
file and who's going to support them
okay well let's continue the line if we
have indeed seen the move Knight B5
makes perfect sense let me drop I I
don't want pardon me I don't want to
drop my Pawn on B6 so let me keep it
protected with the move Queen C6 I'm not
saying that yes I am saying I want to
take PA G but no I want to cover the
pawn on B6 for the time being and I I
understand what you're saying that with
a knight on B5 if you can uh stall or
stop me from breaking through on the a
file then I've invested a lot of time
going nowhere with my Rooks so how do
you do it I'm okay with this if I didn't
have the following move what I want to
know is what's the plan after Bishop D2
Bishop David to you're saying that the
Rook on
A5 uh doesn't have a good
Square I don't feel there's enough
squares on the a file to actually
accommodate both Rooks I understand what
you're saying so let me just again
maintain the
iion that I'm actually going to make uh
some serious hay on the a foul I'll play
the move Rook A4 and I'll play what
exactly you're thinking I'm going to
play Knight C3 no no d33 absolutely and
now and now indeed you for sure without
question now you will have driven my
Rook back so uh black has spent a number
of Tempe with the Rooks but on the other
hand maybe black has gained something by
inducing the move B2 B3 again from my
point of view on a very good day I'll be
able to play Knight D5 Bishop F6 and
generate threats like Rook takes A2 I
absolutely agree that'll be a fantastic
day it'll be a very good day if it all
works out but it's a long way from
getting there right what worries me is
what I said earlier space where are you
going to put all of your pieces for
example let me play a move just wasting
a Tempo and just to make you mad I'm
going to play F3 so you can never take
on G2 I move un necessary
but it's a very decent looking move now
again I've got a problem here what am I
going to do with my pieces I see that if
I go Knight D5 I might run into issues
with C4 and Bishop E4 right my queen
abolutely that's my plan yeah then my
queen is not a happy camper anymore on
the C uh six square okay for the moment
my Rook on f8 is doing nothing let me at
least try to activate it for the time
being and let me play the move that you
suggested anyway C2 C4 or yes is that
right absolutely tell me what do you
think of this specif I like white a it's
a but it's a pawn where also you
blockaded You' stalled the attack the
Knight on B5 actually is done very very
very nicely this did not work out for
VAR so let me try again uh in this case
after wow I don't like Queen E5 I was a
I
was I was going to say that I want to
put pressure but I forgot that I'm just
blundering my Pawn on B6 so right Queen
E5 is is not uh available queen6 was
played I believe on the board Bishop D2
this is a very straightforward move I
played the move Rook A4 thinking I was
inducing a
weakness maybe I have to do something
really crazy uh should my Rook maybe fly
all the way across the
board W but what's it doing on the H4 I
mean I don't know uh but it wasn't doing
too much on A8 let's just continue this
line of inquiry for just a moment I like
what you did last time in the previous
variation which is you just played it
slowly with F2 F3
um try it again the same why not why not
F2 F3 yeah uh why I try to fix a clock
that's not broken Knight
D5 I like white I I simply like white
very much in fact try to trap your Rook
now yeah maybe with a G3 but I even if
you even if you went for a variation
where you traded and one day uh put a
bishop on e4 it's it's all white it's
all white very strange decision by
virgin aov in my opinion hikaro has
played the move Bishop D2 as we more or
less suggested and
yes a com went back to A8 immediately
immediately and we're going to have to
see if he has enough compensation we'll
have to now I'm more doubtful now you're
convincing me that uh F2 F3 in this
Knight on B5 is really blocking black
from you know Landing any hay maker uh
absolutely yeah we're going to take a
look at this game and many others when
we come back from a short commercial
break
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world
but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor
louis.com
[Music]
welcome to chess.com chess.com is social
now you can play chess with your friends
whenever you want whether that's middle
of the day or middle of the night you
can get instantly matched up with one of
over 5 million other members from around
the world you play live games in Real
Time turn-based games at your
convenience or tournaments with anyone
at any time chess.com is mobile you can
play online from your computer or you
can play on the go from your tablet or
your smartphone no matter where you go
whether you're at work grabbing a bite
to eat or just enjoying some time at the
park your games are there with you and
keeping multiple chess games going has
never been easier chess.com is for
learning don't just play chess get
better the best chess training resources
have never been more accessible learn
essential chess STP strategy quickly and
easily with the extremely popular
tactics trainer tool improve your game
in ways you didn't were possible with
training videos by Chess Masters and
regardless of where you're at now take
your game to the next level with
multiple simple to use training
tools chess.com is for everyone over 250
million chess games have been played on
chess.com
and it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner or a
Grandmaster chess.com is the place Place
to Play and Learn chess so create your
free account now and see what chess.com
is for
[Music]
you we are back in the US chess
championships here in St Louis we got
some fascinating games today some
strange decisions and some brilliant
attacks you might want to are looking at
some of the more strategically
complicated games that we have going on
well I must say Alejandra the game
between Alisa and PF has uh captured our
attention just because of the different
uh strategical motives that are going on
um for both of us we were sitting there
saying boy you take on E1 and then you
start thinking Knight E4 and we've been
looking at this line of Bishop takes uh
E4 D takes E4 I was thinking that if I
were going to play this position as
white I would look at Queen F6 and you
correctly pointed out you're always
worried that uh one day when this Knight
does get to
C4 you might end up with a bad dark
Square Bishop absolutely hence the idea
pardon me hence the idea of Queen
E2 with the plan
of advancing these two pawns on the
queen side makes a lot of sense uh in
connection with Bishop E3 and C4 C5 and
suddenly TAF is thrown uh on the
defensive right and this is
a
remarkably uh cool uh strategic idea for
white and
uh that being intrigued if it gets
played that being said we analyzed that
Queen takes E1 for us is such a natural
move yes of course but speaking about
that how unnatural is it to give up your
good Bishop on D3 on D3 that is your
Bishop that's the one that's taking
advantage of the weak squares on the
queen side without question and then
suddenly you're giving it away yeah
exactly I wouldn't have uh given Bishop
E4 that much thought uh we're talking
specifically about the position at hand
I understand the bishop on G5 is under
attack by the Knight but rather than
playing a move like Bishop takes E4 I
would probably tuck this bishop back and
I would be thinking to myself boy if I
could get one day to play move like C5
C4 and I I feel like I could always play
Bishop E4 so why do it right away and
maybe it's one of those things where
timing is a key element as to what's
happening in this position timing is
everything and speaking of timing we're
looking at a fascinating B Gambit game
was declined okay in which black was
able to very timely break in the center
well was it that timely
Maurice very timely in fact and this
game has exploded it's a game we have
not been looking at too closely between
the young arua verk could who won her
game yesterday against Alyssa Melina and
nazzi pidi who is also a newcomer to the
competition but look at this position
black you see the the pawn formation is
amorphus it looks more like a
bloomenfeld than a bko but the position
exploded after she played the move D5
she just wants a piece of the central
action and the computer is giving Bishop
C2 staying cool calm and collect in this
position but the young player played the
move E5 bypassing the pawn but look at
this dangerous diagonal that she has
left alone and the black black in this
position said H you don't have to tell
me twice let's go D4 a mate threat on
the board also attacking the Knight on
C3 and this forcing line actually looks
like it's going to be a huge Advantage
for black because the most natural move
Knight C4 runs into Knight to H5 a
discovered attack on this bishop Bishop
is just purely hanging and if you drop
back well the big question is uh what if
I borrow this from you I me meaning
borrow till the next game this just
looks like a free pawn and the engine
screaming it looks like a free Pawn so
we think that black is in the driver's
seat here white in a lot of trouble
after this big time move
d4 looks like uh she might get a win
after our after ver could had actually
won her first game this would be a very
bad result obviously but still a lot of
ways to go guys the think that these
players are so young and yet even though
it's Nazi's first US Championship she
has an incredible amount of experience
at her Peak rating she was well over
2450 that is amazing for a female player
especially at her young age and she is
had some problems she is getting
adjusted to the American Life sty to her
career in college so she was recruited
by the University of Maryland at
Baltimore County for one of for the
chest team right and of course it's
always difficult to adjust but at her
Peak my godess this girl strong wow and
how old is she then I believe she's 21
pretty impressive so she must be have
been playing chess most of her life a
youngster uh and originally from she's
from Georgia originally Georgia
absolutely former Soviet Republic uh now
independent nation of Georgia so she's
looking good a game we haven't seen by
the way is between ruson and uh Sabina
uh
very
unusual uh position
uh we have a what would we call this
ready where white where white moved her
Knight and then moved I thought in this
position rousan uh was planning an you
know a kingside attack Advance F4 you
move your knight on F3 to get out of the
way the F paon but then she had second
thoughts moved it back one of the most
hardest thing in chess beside trying to
beside winning a one position is
admitting a mistake and taking a move
back that is almost impossible I'd
rather lose my game to take your move
back right like you're what you you want
to be true to yourself but she did play
the movement back Knight F3 H6 so a slow
developing game in this particular game
and um slow is a nice word would you go
as far as saying
unambitious especially by white yeah not
not necessarily because sometimes
especially in today's highly charged
theoretical uh battles sometimes it's
just a very nice idea to postpone the
battle until the time trouble right if
you you have the confidence in yourself
that you're you've got a good Keen
tactical eye you can make strategical
decisions uh practical strategic
decisions uh it sometimes it's a good uh
to slow play and just postpone the
battle bring your pieces into the center
and um try to take advantage of your
trumps having said that I always liked
it when my opponent who was white didn't
try to kill me you know from move one
through 14 but allowed me to get a an
even position so whoever plays well will
win this game yeah this actually reminds
me a lot of the style of some of the top
Egyptian players both Amed Ali and Basim
ASM and they're very well known for
having a pretty dubious repertoire with
white right but they're tactically very
dangerous and they play very quickly so
you get into time pressure in this kind
of complicated position that you're not
familiar with Bam Bam Bam tactics it's
over and the thing I'm not liking so
much about Russ's approach so actually
she's behind on the clock has she been
able to keep up her Pace to be able to
put pressure on the clock on sabinaa I
would have say hey this might actually
be going towards that direction but
right now I feel like she's a little bit
on the clueless side good point I didn't
uh pay too much attention to the clocks
there uh if I were white just to uh make
a suggestion as to what I would play i'
probably drop back my Bishop uh to F1
in a sense uh preparing advance but also
in a in a greater sense saying I don't
really like my Bishop on E2 i' prefer to
Fen Shadow it again I the idea of Bishop
F1 is to play G3 and Bishop G2 and then
again to look for an opportunity uh to
advance in the center with E3 E4
possibly even rerouting the Knight
knight2 F4 and back to time management
wouldn't you do this Play Bishop F1 then
think yes exactly I play uh Bishop F1
right away right and then start thinking
okay let's see some games that have more
um okay this was the game that we've
been looking at uh will'll go up to the
men's games for a moment I'm going to go
to table one uh by the way we
saw uh your move I liked it very much
this slow play F2 F3 it's not just that
you're taking away this diagonal
effectively
but you're also introducing the
possibility of Bishop E4 you're kind of
keeping that Knight on F6 honest if you
will then came the move Bishop A6 I feel
that uh VAR is kind
of
oh yeah he's trying to create in a
position where there he's not being
allowed the opportunity to be creative
Bishop A6 would have been you know down
my list of candidate moves type of thing
and uh C2 C4 right away by um uh hikaro
and again looks like he's a very safe
Pawn up for the time being I like his
position well other positions are not so
clear we're going to go back to the US
Women's Champions game okay
Mar a lot of interesting game on the
ladies side certainly the one between
our top seed Arena Crush she's
definitely starting to get a little bit
of control over the game now she's a
positional player she likes to squeeze
you she's not a person who loves to
attack and play Wild chess so in that
sacrificial line you had mentioned
earlier y it's not it's a kind of line
she would shy away from unless it were
clear to her that she was getting great
compensation but take a look at what she
did in her game now against Victoria KN
she played the move A4 typical of her
style and after Knight to A6 A5 getting
that clamp on the queen side of the
board and after King to F7 move just so
that she could be able to Castle by hand
Bishop E2 King to G7 now the king is
safe on that side Bishop E3 Bishop to D7
just bringing out more pieces Rook to B1
applying pressure down the open file now
Bishop to E8 guarding this Pawn with the
queen and now Queen to D2 and White's
trying to tickle black a little bit and
now the move Rook to B8 overprotecting
this Pawn to free the queen and now you
would think maybe Arena would play a
natural move like castles or maybe even
Knight G4 some some kind of trading
lines
G4 with the potential for playing H4 or
even just playing G5 by itself so G4 a
big time move saying I'm the one in
control of the position and I'm looking
to win the game and show why I the
champion here and her opponent I believe
has moved after G4 she played the move
Knight back to D7 and it's definitely a
morphous interesting crazy structure
we've seen these structures before will
this dark Square Bishop have it say in
the position or will White's pawns prove
to be weak definitely a contentious game
in that one with the top woman in the
competition
guys interesting 97 I I like 97 you do
it's it's the kind of positions where
okay Black's not doing anything it's
just I'm here I'm solid I don't care
what you throw at me I'll just respond
accordingly the problem for arena I
think will be trying to actually break
through on the king side if we see a
very typical reaction for black here is
to just sit wait and when white pushes
one of her pawns forward I'll say thank
you I'll decline the trade push my own
Pawn forward block a the king side say
there's nothing going on nothing's going
to happen my king is safe we're going to
play 100 moves of Chess and I'm going to
be okay a 100 moves of Chess I like that
okay I thought that Victoria was going
to take a completely different approach
than the one she did when I saw the move
it was back at the these parts when I
saw the move Bishop E8 I was absolutely
certain that what Victoria had in mind
was to play the move
G5 and trying to uh limit the scope of
the darkware bishop on E3 but more so to
play the move G5 followed by Bishop G6 I
was 100% sure that was where she was
going with her play after Queen D2 Rook
B8 G4 I would have lost a a good wager I
I'm I'm curious why she didn't play G5 I
obviously
H4 uh again I'm kind of of I'm taking a
stand if you will over the G5 Square for
a moment so I want to play the move
Bishop G6 so I can introduce the idea of
Knight takes E4 and let me express my
greed very very clearly I want your Rook
uh if I could induce white just for a
moment let's just say white defends her
Pawn on C uh on e4 then I wanted to play
Knight H7 so I'm I'm trying to take a
stand if you will over the G5 Square Pro
perhaps it's too provocative but I
thought this was what what Victoria had
in mind I think this is just too much I
think this is too risky um because this
is not her game plan she's simply
waiting at the moment you're playing so
active you're playing right I want to
play active well I thought the move
Bishop E8 was the Prelude uh to playing
active actually it's funny how play
Styles come into chess you know most
people look at Bishop E8 and some people
will say this is a passive defensive
move you look at it like I'm rerouting
my Bishop to the most active scare I can
find exactly two different styles of
playing I think that right now Victoria
is just looking to hold it's possible
that uh she wants to play G5 if the time
permits but she would love it more if
it's after white plays H4 H5 right okay
so what you're basically saying and
Victoria is basically saying is I'll
keep my pawns on G6 and H6 whenever
white plays the move H4 I'll do
something let's say like say Knight C7
and if white plays G5 I'll happily keep
the king side closed by playing H5 in
response if white plays H5 same idea
I'll respond with G5 keeping everything
closed and as we know the two Bishops
love open positions less so and closed
positions the only question here is will
there be a some kind kind of sacrifice
or some kind of way of exploiting the
king position we're going to have to
take that look at that a little bit
later we're going to go for our second
break of the day and we will also have
for you a puzzle between the players
Gutman and of course our US champion
participant Ray Robson playing in the
national open in Las Vegas all
right
[Music]
e
we are back the 2015 US championship and
2015 US Women's Championship with our
amazing commentator team C Sahan Maurice
Ashley myself Alejandra vamz and well so
far we got somewhat slow games a lot of
maneuvering today a lot of maneuvering
but yeah not simulating attacks but uh
the players uh I'm especially admiring
what's happening in the game of hakaru
Nakamura the number one seed he slow
slowly slowly just simply taking over
all the major squares he's a pawn
ahead no problem his King is an absolute
safety and he's looking really good but
not so slow was the solution to the
puzzle from Ray Robson and we got
Maurice Ashley giving
us indeed in this position Ray Robson
found himself with the black pieces down
in exchange but with a culating attack
and I'm sure all of you in the audience
solved this puzzle but you had to see
one fine point and that is black to move
clearly has a lot of pressure on the
king and the move Bishop takes A2
ripping apart White's kingside now if
you look at the position it looks like
white has a nice little threat here why
not play Queen down we know about the
back rank mate however a nice little
cheeky move Knight back to E8 giving up
a rook well not quite because of course
after Queen takes Rook we have this very
standard maneuver that checkmates quite
easily on C2 so I'm sure all of you saw
that move Bishop takes on A2 are the
ones who were terrified at the back rang
mate uh go back to your combination
books guys back to you nice one thank
you Maurice uh moving to our table
number three I guess I'm going to look
at the game between Ray Robson and
Alexander onuk we go back ways we were
at these parts and remember
uh the difficulty we had at this point
Ray decided to capture and Advance his
Pawn D5 Knight E7 and this nice move I
like this move a lot by Ray Knight
repositions itself on F3 it's always
vulnerable to an E5 E4 uh shot however
with the Knight coming to D2 now these
two beautiful outposts for the Knight
either the C4 square or the E4 Square
Queen A5 going after the Pawn on
D5 Knight comes to E4 Queen takes D5
train a trade on D5 pardon me and Rook
D1 by Ray in order to uh win back his
Pawn on D6 Knight F4 while we were on
break Alejandra you and I were saying I
like White's position but you were
thinking yeah but it's it's just going
to dissolve into a draw and what you
specifically were thinking about was
like if if Ray just goes for all of the
captures and Rook takes D6 you're
probably thinking well gee after Rook E2
uh there's a lot of uh more trading
going on and you'll get into a drawn
rook and ending like counter play is
very serious it's true that Black's Pawn
structure at this point is absolutely
horrible but that's not going to matter
when there's no pawns left I'm gonna
take all of your queen side you're gonna
take all of my King's side I don't think
there's any good way for Robson to make
any progress on his choke he's going to
hold this I think with a certain amount
of confidence okay let's just see how
that would go so imagine for example we
played a move like Rook C1 imagining
that you would play Rook C8 now I'm
worried about back rank M threats so I'm
going to encourage you to capture on C2
right away and we'll get some position
like
this and now if I try to wipe you out
over here I'll take on B2 and I'll wipe
you out over over here and I'm not
afraid of this
position because uh you're thinking that
we'll just trade the B Pawn for the a
pawn and whatever happens on the king
side is just a dead draw and I think
that's worst case scenario I'm going to
force your hand let me play F3 in this
position necessary probably not but you
forc me to rupture my Pawn structure as
well and now you have the worst kind of
three versus two on the king side that
on a good case scenario it's usually
drawn yes and now this one that drawn
agreed yeah so fair enough on that game
let's go to that game some high fut
maneuvering going on for a long time
between the youngest competitor in the
tournament Sam savan against five-time
US champion and defending Champion
gotsky uh from a Brer uh variation the
players have played quite standard up to
this moment from God's point of view
he's trying to bring his Knight to this
beautiful blockading Square D6 and white
says fine you get a good knight but I've
got all of
the breaks in the position H5 and you
were saying that in your when you were
going up against Scot aapsky for the US
Championship you guys had tied for first
you found yourself after two rapid games
uh going into an Armageddon and in your
preparation you were hoping to have uh a
Brer defense cuz you had prepared this
time type of position where you thought
you could keep g under uh lock and key
so to speak no break well it was
actually for my rapid game against G we
did end up playing a Spanish but it
wasn't specifically this variation right
it was a he castled quickly threatening
to go into the Marshall and now uh
quickly broke with A4 completely
different variation but I also want to
point out the evolution of Chess a
little bit please we got Samuel savan
one of the youngest participants one of
the youngest Grand Masters in the world
playing this slow positional torturous
coroian type of positions and that's not
something that happened when I was a kid
no no of course when when I was a kid I
was 15 I was a Grandmaster we were all
expected to play this sharp nidor those
dragons the king Indians go for the
opponent's throat and then eventually
that would uh extinguish from our uh
soul and eventually would die down and
play all these kind of boring positions
but I see how the new generation is
embracing this type of Maneuvers and
this subtleties in the position so much
quicker something that really struck me
was that when I saw Jennifer U yesterday
play against Anish revich the very first
game move in that game struck me as
different she played the move
C4 and that's not something that you
usually go around teaching students you
don't go around saying hey open the game
C4 it's a move that you learn after a
lot of subtlety and a lot of
understanding that there's a specific
difference between starting with D4 and
C4 even if you want to transpose into
each other something that well
apparently it's very well understood by
somebody that's 133 years old right it's
amazing so you're saying uh that we all
start in this romantic style of attack
and sacrifice and get the tactics and
get those checkmating attacks under your
belt as you mature as you begin to
understand more about the subtleties of
Chess you start embracing a little bit
more positional uh maneuvering and the
fact that Sam Sean is playing against
one of the most experienced uh players
in the US Championship a veteran
five-time winner played for the world
championship against anat karpa and here
we see Sam Sean saying I'm going to out
maneuver you I mean not what you expect
from the youngster very good points but
sometimes you don't need Maneuvers to
win games Maurice do you have some
updates for us that's right one player
who really detests maneuvering except
when he's got a gun to your head is
Hikaru Nakamura and it looks like uh his
opponent May may have blundered after
having given up a pawn to sacrifice
something now it looks like he may have
simply lost at least an exchange or
maybe another pawn and you can see it
just in the body language yaru is was
like give me some food take a look at
this position the last move played here
after Bishop to C3 we saw these last
couple of moves Whit's clamping down on
this side of the board saying I don't
see your compensation I'm just up a pawn
let me figure out how to do it and now
Queen to C5 and maybe white was thinking
I'll have to make a few moves to show my
advantage but now bam Bishop to D4 has
shown up on the board and this move says
I'm looking for concrete material gains
more stuff why is that well first of all
we can see if you dare to try to grab
two pieces for The Rook you're going to
get hit by this discovery and thanks
very much for your queen so we know
that's not going to happen but what else
can he do his Pawn on B6 the second Pawn
on the queen side that pawn he s
sacrifice earlier in the game it's about
to go down too because if you Tred to
just say oh okay my bad I'm going to
save it now well let's look at the other
side of the board where you'll lose an
exchange this way no matter what veran
is going to go down more stuff and this
is starting to look really bad for him
looks like Nakamura is in complete
cruise control now dominating the game
seems like he's going to chalk up this
win quite easily guys remarkable easily
because when he decided to accept that
Gambit Pawn I thought he was going to
have to be uh uh U fiercely defending
let's say for a half a dozen dozen moves
at least and instead um VAR really
hasn't done anything with after
sacrificing the pawn and this whole
maneuver with Rook on A8 to A5 back to
A8 actually ended up simply costing him
Tempe well I blame it on all the tempy
Lost I mean I just want to point this
out let's go back to the move 13 just
after hikaro takes on B6 right right and
we have a queen on C7 and Rook on A8
Bishop on E7 and let's go back an
important seven moves later okay well so
from this position we're just going to
jump to the next one which is well we
well I'm not going to be able to jump
let me just go and we'll jump to the
next one The Rook still on A8 Bishop
still on E7 Knight still on F6 he moved
the bishop to A6 and his Rook on f8 to
d8 so he's only made two Progressive
moves over how many did we say seven or
so that's just bad I that's not he was
down upon he had to actually show his
compensation right did he do that not at
all not at all so we're going to go back
once again to the position where the
pawn sacrificed appeared I mean and
you're saying in in these seven moves as
black I would have definitely have
gotten in at least a knight D5 at least
a bishop F6 and a bishop on B7 and in
fact he never even got in a knight D5 at
all and these pieces the bishop on E7
and the Knight on F6 remain rooted and
then as Maurice's just pointed out
following Bishop B4 White's actually
going to go up even more material
and positions lost essentially usually
in Chaz tactics favor the player that
has the advantage and you create
advantages with putting your pieces in
good places having good Pawn structures
aoan didn't put his pieces in good
places it's no surprise that tactics are
working against him Bingo well said um
moving to table number two we have
Wesley so the other pre-tournament
favorite
um they've been playing a Spanish
torture for some time at the end of the
day what have we got we still have a
little space edge uh but beyond that is
it much for white this bishop on B7 does
make a woeful impression at the moment
Sam Shanklin into play and uh Knight has
just appeared on F4 what do you think
about Knight F5 uh returning the favor
but at least in this problem on D3 no
problems Knight Rook C5 first oh pardon
me I beg your pardon at Knight I was
suggesting Knight F5 let's toss in a
rook C5 perhaps there's no
I'll have to drop back with the queen
just to keep my Bishop protected at the
moment I'm eyeballing this Pawn on D6 MH
the idea well the idea I wanted to show
is that in case of Trades and if you
played a move like this then I was
trying to exploit oops uh a pin along
the a file
so Wesley still has to
uh solve isn't is Rook
C3 an idea do you feel that it's
actually white that's playing for the
initiative I understand that you have a
little bit of a space advantage and you
have some problems on the D6 Pawn right
but on the other hand don't you feel
that The Rook has the C file there are
some problems on F2 there's some
problems on the third rank there's some
problems on the second rank but it's
actually white that has to be a little
bit careful not to fall for some trick
right and that could be very that could
very well be the case Cas here uh my
knight F5 may be an overreach sometimes
when you o when you you you you take a
large share of the center let's say you
can overextend and what you're talking
about there is um this idea that uh
White has this big Edge in space but on
the other hand uh the supply lines you
know like he could overextend maybe uh
Sam has to you know well
as you were pointing out if he pulls in
his horns and goes like Bishop uh back
to F1 then this Rook comes to C2 and
again it's sort of
like hey wait a minute did Black just
steal the initiative or you know there's
some pressure absolutely and it does
seem that we have an update in one of
the more fiery games of today all righty
Maurice take it
away indeed quite fiery that game we saw
between an shich and Karina mova the
black player here had pushed all her
pawns down the board and she's saying
I'm looking to win the game after she
slipped up yesterday from the game it
looked like she should have won also
she's now playing very aggressive Queen
A4 though by sharich Rook to B8 uh sorry
King to B8 and now a trade in the middle
followed by B4 looking for her own pawn
pawn storm excuse me pawn storm on that
side of the board and the move Bishop to
D6 after a deep think she played this
move and you have to really see how
deeply she went into this position
beautiful tactical idea if you play the
move Bishop takes on D5 looking to win a
pawn well Bishop to G3 is the first
thing that pops into your brain but wait
a second can't white just play Bishop
takes Knight and after you take back
just grab your Bishop looks free not
quite because Queen D5 suddenly and the
white king is fully exposed if you try
to defend with the Queen takes on C6
Rook H1 check appears out of nowhere you
were trying to defend but it didn't work
and after you move then a simple trade
here and thank you for your rook in the
corner That's How Deeply she went into
the position when she played the move
Bishop to D6 finding a beautiful line
her opponent to her credit saw it as
well and declined taking the pawn on D5
instead playing the move B5 now black
dropping back with Knight to E7 guarding
her pawn and you have to look look at
the board and say where's White's
initiative it doesn't seem as though
white has any real initiative here and
he's back to black thinking about moves
like F4 prying open in the king side it
seems that black with her daring play is
going to pay off at least for the moment
she's in the driver's seat here at the
Women's Championship guys and just to
add what you were saying Maurice I do
see this move F2 F4 uh by
Anna after the move Knight E7 clearly
Anna didn't want to allow her opponent
the opportunity to play F5 F4 and played
F4 herself but this is a very big uh
strategic decision because it's allowing
black the opportunity uh to have an open
G file or a half open G file and I've
got to say that Kate's I played Anna
absolutely after this move F4 I don't I
want to say it's an ugly move an ugly
move never want to play that yeah I
didn't want to do it myself but uh maybe
it was the nature of the position but
for sure she was was fearful of an F5 F4
by black she played F4 and the things
that I
would not want to have to face is like
just what am I going to do when black
starts bringing as many pieces over to
the king side and maybe even looking for
an opportunity to sacrifice on the on
the F4 Pawn n saw has done a beautiful
job of controlling those Bishops notice
that even though we have a faneto bishop
on G2 Bishop on D2 they're doing nothing
well the bishop on G2 is always the good
loyal guard okay right I mean it's it's
defending the king for the moment the
that the bishop on D2 is absolutely not
uh played a role it would be a very
different uh case if White had a rook uh
a Rover with Rook a rook C3 to A3 but
this bishop on D6 is simply excellent
it's uh defending the C7 Pawn to begin
with but it's looking in both directions
including defending the square A3 I like
Kate's position I love Kate's position I
think she's playing a fantastic game I
think shich is going to be forced to
find difficult moves and we know that
all the players in the championship
they're already thinking about time
pressure yeah sh's down to 19 minutes
and 53 seconds which considering the
fact that she has 20 moves left to go to
move 40 for another 30 minutes it's not
much right well that's an interesting
thing about time trouble too you know
you get into time trouble but it and if
if you were a blitz player you would
think okay I got three minutes to make
eight moves no no problem but it's not
Blitz when you're when you're getting
into time trouble you're getting nervous
about the fact that you're in time
trouble and your thoughts are getting
occupied by the clock and sometimes this
just leads
to catastrophe you just over you get you
blunder it's such a difficult transition
to make you're comfortably thinking for
20 minutes about the Strategic nuances
of moving the bishop one square or two
and then suddenly you're trying not to
get mated and you have 30 seconds to
make a decision completely different
ball game very very difficult to
participate and make those transitions
it's just different ball game exactly
and again uh that's what chess is uh you
keep putting the pressure on your
opponent you not not necessarily uh a
winning threat or things like that but
by uh constantly uh putting uh difficult
decisions awkward decisions for your
opponent to make that's how your
advantages increase let me just uh
Maurice please uh take it speaking about
time pressure I mean time pressure makes
fools of us all right you talk about
that sweat Blood Sweat and Tears you put
into all those moves and you look at
your clock and go Oh no I got to move
right now that's what's going to happen
in a game that we have been looking at
between Alysa mahina and tatev
abrahamyan because after this move 94
remember that that tat went into a big
think and decided not to take this Rook
she played Knight E4 well it seems as
though Alyssa went into an even bigger
think and decided not to play Bishop
takes on e4 which was the computer
suggestion which to our eyes is somewhat
anti- themematic and maybe didn't lead
anywhere but she spent some time on that
move and instead she played Bishop A6
check keeping her Bishops and after King
B8 Queen to D3 trying to bring her
pieces over to that side Queen D6 he
dropped her Bishop back now we just have
the pieces kind of quieting down and
saying all right let's see what happens
next in the maneuvering phase and now
the move F5 looking to clamp down on the
F3 Square maybe get an attack going
sorry on the E4 square but after F3
Knight F6 and now Bishop to B5 and Rook
to E6 now black has definitely made some
progress here in this position but at
what cost she has only 12 minutes and 41
seconds on the clock she does have 30
second increments but she has 18 moves
she has to make 18 moves you hate being
an under a minute a move with so much to
play for she's looking kind of calm and
cool right there but that is beying the
fact that there's no question the the
energy is churning inside you know we
say chess players have to have a poker
face well this is the chess face right
here this is like e you know I'm okay
meantime she's thinking oh my God what's
going to happen next so time pressure
yes is going to break out on a lot of
boards we see other games as well I
remember I was looking at another game
from the open look at this one
naroditsky versus Kaden tro and Kaden is
even in worse situation he has 13
minutes and 45 seconds and he's only at
move 17 so he's in a really bad state
with 23 moves to make for time control
so we will see these games heating up
quite rapidly in about 15 or so minutes
all heck is going to break loose in the
Championships guys well I wanted to
point out I was talking to tatev
yesterday actually after her loss
against tny Wang and well no natural
question what happened where'd you lose
and okay the easy the easy answer is I
blund during time pressure but we go a
little bit further where did T raham and
lose her game yesterday in my opinion
and from what we talked about she lost
the game when she spent 15 minutes on
castling it's a move that she should
have
done thought thought after she would
have had plenty of time to calculate the
consequences of the of the crazy
happenings in time pressure right and
she would have been able to perhaps not
lose the game right so this is just an
impractical decision one of the things
that has happened over the course of
let's say the last 30 years is that in
fact the time control has become more
accelerated that is to say in the old
days you used to have 40 moves for two
and a half hours followed by 16 and one
and you'd have these adjournments some
games would last 10 hours or more now
it's very common that the games are over
after 5 hours hours 6 hours and perhaps
even seven hours so the the players have
to make a lot of practical decisions
quickly and when you when you the old
expression long think wrong think really
uh is a good motto uh that is to say in
this game between Alisa and TV when
Alisa went into a 30 minute think as a
if I were her coach or trainer I would
just slap her hands and say look you're
not going to think for 30 minutes
because because uh at a certain moment
your head starts spinning and then
you're making a bad decision Even after
spending 30 minutes now what's happening
that's a different question I don't know
what's happening in that game turning to
the game of nitki for a moment before we
go into that yeah and we are going
definitely to see this game especially
when it dissolves into time pressure uh
we're going to have a small clip by
Teran schaer on uh the ability of Chess
to improve your brain yes there is
another chess event going on in St Louis
today the cortex Innovation Madness
chess tournament finals are happening
just down the street from the Central
West End here where the chess club of St
Louis is and we have Emily with us from
The Innovation community and you have a
thinking ball that actually some chess
players are using yeah so we created a
product called thinking ball it's a ball
that's used for thinking don't overthink
it it can be about as complex or simple
as you want so there's something called
kinesthetic learning that is really
really really important but isn't
utilized in a lot of areas and so when
you bounce a ball you're dealing with a
different part of your brain so whenever
I'm playing something as complex as
chess I'll bounce the ball I'll make my
move oh and then I'll pass it to
Noah and he will continue on and so
kinesthetic learning is super super
important especially when you're dealing
with complex games so we branded a ball
around it so we actually have had people
in The Innovation District using them
we've seen everyone carrying them around
and bouncing them and really getting
into it we launched an Indiegogo
campaign that ended up being almost 200%
funded so people love our concept and
we're really excited to get it out there
in the Innovation Community as well as
the chess Community yeah that's great
and not only um are you guys utilizing
the chess Community with the thinking
Ball but how else can you kind of relate
The Innovation Community to the chess
club here well you know it's incredible
is I think a lot of people would be
really surprised to find out that the
world that the US uh championship in
chess is here in St Louis in kind of the
middle of the country but the truth is
St Louis has got a great history of uh
of of being a center of intellectuals
and I think that attracts the startup
Community because there are so many
really deep thinkers here who are able
to come up with new things like thinking
ball and uh a lot of people would be
surprised to find out that that's here
but it turns out to be a great place to
to to do Innovation because of that you
have a real high density of really deep
thinkers and great talent but then at
the same time you can just grab your
kids go to the grocery store and kind of
live regular life and see how that
Innovation that you're trying to do is
going to work in the real world yeah
that's great and so a lot of people
don't know the Innovation Community here
in St Louis it's budding all these
startups are happening here in St Louis
just down the street from the chess club
of St
Louis well it seems like we have some
pretty cool development in some of the
games and it was only a two-minute video
marce do you have something for
us well I just saw a game and I thought
when I looked at the moves my immediate
reaction just uncontrollably was wow
like really that's what happened take a
look at the last couple of moves after
the move F4 in this game between Ana
shich and Katarina mova I mean Katarina
is playing some marvelous Chess at first
we doubted the way she was handling the
game and maybe with better play I know
might have been able to get an advantage
but now her audacity is paying off big
time her opponent realizing that she had
no no Chances with white to attack she
decided to try to slow things down with
the move F4 Korina said guess what I've
got something for you the maneuver
Knight to G8 the Knight danced from the
queen side now headed to the king's side
noticing the weak E4 and the weak G4
squares that's not what made me go wow
the move Queen B3 was played attacking
this Pawn she brought her Knight out to
F6 and getting ready now to plunk down
on one of these squares and then
suddenly the move F takes G5
maybe I should have said because that's
just ugly I mean you don't even have to
look any further to know that white must
be busted now under the pressure of her
opponent's bold play it looks as though
an iserovich is going to go down in this
game I can't imagine her saving this
position the Knight simply has to move
maybe E4 is a good square and just look
at the pawns the G3 Pawn is dead to the
world the Queen's going to shift over
white has no attack white White's forget
get it that King is as safe as ever and
it's only white that could possibly get
mated here and it looks like something
really bad is going to happen to the
white position so Karina mova she missed
she played really well yesterday only
not to convert her win today it looks
like she's angry and she's very
determined looking to prove that she is
a contender in this year's championships
guys what a fantastic maneuver Knight G8
Knight F6 Knight E4 I had thought about
it and immediately find it because I
thought D5 was hanging she just didn't
care no nice play nice play great
maneuver unbel and the Knight just like
is suddenly going to be a Thor on the E4
Square so when you think again about her
Kate's first uh game first round pairing
where gosh she was a pawn up
overwhelming position if she had
converted what looked uh to our eyes to
be a simple wind she'd be sitting pretty
at 2 2 uh but at the the moment uh very
very nice play with black pieces against
one of the pre-tournament favorites Anna
shich and Kate is doing well talking
about pre-tournament favorites I'll turn
to table one in the
open uh indeed after this move Bishop D4
by Hikaru
Nakamura uh realizing that well he's
about to blunder more material or had
blundered more material VAR steep back
with his Queen uh thank you very much
that's a very important Pawn now a 30 uh
majority on the queen side makes it an
absolute that you know every single end
game in the world is now unplayable for
VAR after Bishop takes B6 Rook D7 the
bishop Dro back and just no compensation
uh from this point onwards allaro is
thinking about is let's trade as many
pieces off the board as we can
and um VAR is sitting there saying well
I've got to get some kind kind of thing
going on the queen side he played the
move Bishop C5 but he's looking at a
lost cause this is completely hopeless I
think right Karo has excellent technique
he's proven that he's evolved as a chest
player in many many facets he's up to
pawns there's no serious threats he's
very good at calculating he's up a
considerable amount of time as well yeah
I mean I just don't see this happening I
just don't see any comeback and as you
were mentioning it was kind of a pity
for n SOA not to be able to beat rusa
goani yesterday especially you know up
upon having having a mating attack
having everything going her way she
really needs that confident boost that
she has a winning position and she could
finish it off exactly uh moving to our
second table uh Wesley so as black uh
Sam Shanklin when we had left it uh you
had uh introduced the the idea some
doubts that uh Sam's position might be a
little bit overextended uh the queen in
fact did drop back to B3 Sam recognizing
that he needs to control this Rook by
protecting uh Square C3 as well as C2
drop back with a
queen um Wesley's problem was he had
this light Square Bishop that was doing
nothing he played Bishop B7 to A6
unfortunately for white because the
bishop on D3 is hanging there are no he
doesn't have the time for moves like
Rook A3 or queen A3 to take advantage
because simply Knight takes D3 Bishop
trade was played and now the Knight
jumped to F5 and interesting tactics
start to uh this move Knight F5 kind of
allows Knight E2 Knight E4
ideas but at the moment white has his
own tactics on the air right yes this 97
check uh forking King as well as Rook
what happened after Knight F5 was King
H7 Sid stepping the Knight E7 threat and
hoping to dispel this Knight with the
move G7 G6 the black king protects the
pawn on
H6 Queen B4 and we're up to date with
this position and we'll take it over to
Maurice to look at one of the more
interesting structures of today's games
indeed a chaotic structure in this
position and the problem of knights I
know you guys have heard of the problem
of the wrong Rook this game features the
problem of the wrong Knight
let's take a look at the position again
between young aruo ver could and nazzi
pidi in this position we remember this
game black was supposed to play the move
Knight H5 according to the engines quite
anti-human move but the Knight would
have been much better place on this
Square it would not have blocked this
long diagonal with the bishop and queen
having pressure instead she played
Knight D5 Bishop H2 and she said still
it's a pawn up and so far theine said
yes this is good too now Queen to G4
PA down but trying to get her own attack
on the king side of the board and this
was the moment of the problem of the
wrong night which night do you put on F6
yes I'm going to ask you the question
which night do you put on F6 put you on
the spot you got three
seconds D7 D7 Knight you would have been
wrong because that's exactly what she
did she plays the other Knight was the
one remember again the long diagonal is
important to release it so instead she
did use the D7 Knight and now Queen to
H4 and after a trade on this square and
queen C7 check King G1 now white has
stabilize the position and what we're
seeing is that this Knight was guarding
this C5 Pawn so a rookie is going to end
up on C1 no problem the long diagonal
threat that's gone so white was down a
clear Pawn before like no issues at all
but now you start looking say well
things are not that bad you know some
chances she's got a little pressure
she's organized her forces she is down
the pawn but it's not so easy to execute
anymore and the engines are saying a
little smidget of an advantage for the
black pieces so an unusual position lots
of interesting uh Maneuvers with these
Knights they're tricky buggers and as we
can see here and in other games as the
championship starts to get to time
control and some time pressure speaking
of the knights being tricky I mean we
were just looking at this idea in Sam
shanklin's game all the tactics with the
Knights well we were kind of wondering
what exactly
shankland was planning to do on the move
night3 right so uh uh Wesley had just uh
when we had left it had played the move
King H7 uh sidest stepping the threat of
Knight E7 check and preparing the
possibility of G6 Sam said hey wait a
minute I'm attacking your D6 Pawn let me
play the move Queen B4 which has the
good idea of first uh protecting the
pawn on e4 but more concretely the idea
of capturing this Pawn on D6 but did he
leave himself vulnerable to Knight D3
for King the queen as well as the
Rook the natural move would be Queen
takes D6 maybe even forced move I don't
see any other way yes exactly the
natural enforced move Queen takes D6 and
white might be thinking oh this is just
wonderful if we trade and I take the
Rook well I'll get your rook and at the
moment uh I'm a pawn to the good so
clearly that would favor um white but in
this moment Wesley has some nice little
uh tricks here he's by no means uh
compelled to trade queens and he might
be start thinking well like maybe I
could come down here Queen can come over
here I've still got this threat I've
still got ideas of Knight takes E4 those
haven't gone away after for example I
don't know Rook F1 you got to protect F2
I've got
ideas Rook could come down to C1 Rook
could come to C2 Knight's coming to E4
this is a position where white could
very easily lose control I mean very
easily uh lose control let's not forget
about the fact that after Rook F1 I can
also immediately take on e4 and already
I'm threatening Knight takes F2 for this
reason I'm kind of wondering when you
put the queen on
A2 just humor me and maybe put it on A4
okay sorry this moment Queen takes D6
Queen D6 Queen a not Queen A2 but Queen
A4 right away the idea is that when you
do move your
Rook yes from example F1 yes let's just
put it on a square and I take on e4 I
don't not sure what your Queen's where
where my queen is ending up going well
I'm going to have to go here I'm afraid
right uh at least I'm I balling the pawn
on F7 and holding my breath um it's
going to turn into a very double DCH
position but somehow I think that Wesley
should come out on top okay well that's
a that would be a big transformation
Queen B4 very challenging move Maurice
your
thoughts well we're still dealing with
these Knights I mean the night I used to
answer the question what's your favorite
piece by saying the one that
checkmates but lately within the last
several years actually I've come to
really like those kns I think Knights
are exciting pieces but I think in
particular the Knight is a piece that
defies human logic we're very linear are
we humans we like to see things straight
ahead or left right backwards but this
little piece that goes two steps and
turns that one is tricky for beginners
and Grand Masters alike and we see that
one of the one of the great signs of a
strong chess player is the ability to
handle Knights properly we'll take a
look at this nimian knight move in the
game between Arena crush and Victoria
knee this game we saw we we kind of like
Black's position for a while but Arena
got her kind of game and she'd been
holding her opponent at Bay for quite
some time well in fact KN wasn't doing
much but take a look at this knight move
knight from from uh F2 a pawn by the way
on H4 is hanging look at this next move
you guys I think you're going to like it
even if you didn't think White's
position was that great knight to H1
giving away the pawn on H4 Queen takes
on H4 Knight to G3 now the file is open
and she's going to bring her Rook to H1
by the way the point of the Knight going
to H1 was to bring the Knight up to G3
and then push this pawn and steal this
F5 square with her Knight and that was
the whole purpose of this maneuver this
kind of greed takes and now Queen D now
Rook to H1 and now the Knight is waiting
this Pawn is under pressure the the dark
squared Bishop black doesn't have one so
therefore for white wants to use her
dark Square Bishop is pressuring this
Pawn his Pawn's about to drop and if you
push the pawn here comes the Knight into
the position and it's white for Choice
guys great night Maneuvers we're seeing
today very instructive games by a lot of
the players here at the
Championships fascinating games game of
maneuver a round of maneuver it's been
about the nights today yeah okay we're
going to take a quick commercial break
and we'll be back with you guys
soon
2014 was a great year for chess chess 24
brought you live interactive broadcasts
from Top tournaments a Play Zone where
you can take on opponents from all
around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your chest by solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos chess 24 on mobiles
and tablets most features are free but
limited for registered members chess 24
is offering a special premium membership
for just $999 per month or $99 per year
see you at chess24.com
for
[Music]
I'm Mike maeni whether you chance to
come on or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
chess club and Scholastic Center of St
Louis right here in the chess capital of
the US from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 Schools our
Center across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame and the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to
offer
we're in the last few moments before we
actually hit time pressure for most of
the games in the US Championship quite a
defining point of the game of course it
matters how well you've played up to
this point but it also matters how much
time you've accumulated to be able to
either defend your position or convert
your advantage exactly and as the
players do move uh to time control uh
we've been on our break uh thinking that
Wesley so has missed a fantastic
opportunity on the 29th move both
players are pretty close in time 160
minutes to 15 minutes Wesley uh seeing
that his Pawn on D6 was under attack he
simply played the Cool C collected
defensive move Rook d8 however he may
have had a great opportunity with Knight
D3 forking Queen and Rook we were
looking at this variation earlier Queen
takes D6 um the suggestion your
suggestion uh Alejandro was Queen A4
leaving The Rook exposed Rook comes to
F1 and now this very nice move Queen
takes E4 and suddenly Black's pieces are
all beautifully centralized the queen
specifically on e4 the Knight on D3 Pawn
on D5 is hanging in case of the move
Knight E3 then Wesley had the beautiful
followup Rook E3 um setting up for a
knight takes F2 and this looks like a
very good Advantage for Wesley and white
looks so passive in that position
defending against the threats not
producing any of his own weakness on D5
perhaps he could survive but it would
not have been Pleasant yeah exactly that
would have been a real challenge for Sam
to hold that position and for sure I'm
I'm thinking that Sam is relieved that
in a variation we just looked at Wesley
had that opportunity to have an active
Rook the moment he has a passive Rook
doesn't mean to say that he's that all
three results aren't possible it's just
that that's a big opportunity missed
Knight D3 so let's take a quick look at
some of the games some of them easy to
understand for example we have oh
actually a result already a draw has
been agreed between Ray Robson and Alex
Onish you were expecting that uh the
Rooks there would be a lot of Pawn
captures and in fact after a trade of
Rooks they'll get into a drawn rook and
Pawn in the game EX players agreed with
you that's what happened a very funny
game between Sam Sean and gakamsky now
this kind of this last move uh kind of
defies understanding Rook to G1 tripling
on the G file which is absolutely closed
so uh I want you to look inside your
crystal ball and tell me how on Earth is
white uh going to open up the G file
what is the move Rook G1 all about well
is there any idea with playing the
Knight to F5 and if for some reason
black is brave enough to take it I go
play G6 check well there you go that was
uh the thought that I had was that uh
Sam Black's only opportunity to open the
game is based upon this lever F7 F6 and
maybe Sam was simply saying I am never
ever going to allow you that opportunity
I will stop you from playing F6 Forever
by playing Mo uh Rook G1 well speaking
of opportunities let's see if krina n
SOA has been able to do something with
Earth capital A well you look at this
position guys and it's the one that we'd
be at the board going yum yum here I
come because Karina nsovo after playing
wonderful chess is now completely
dominating her opponent Anna sheric and
is about to Simply Crush her it's
looking horrible after this great move
Knight to G8 Queen B3 Knight over to F6
beautiful maneuver that prompted her
opponent to panic and take on G5 not
many great choices but that one
certainly suicidal after Knight to E4
attacking the pawn on G3 Bishop back to
E1 and now finally after opening that H5
oh so many moons ago a queen has
appeared on that square Queen H7 now
looking at the H2 square and queen takes
D5 in response now come on you know
that's got to leave a mark after Bishop
takes G3 a discovery on the queen and
we're waiting here for her move actually
no she did play Queen to E6 and black
now is on move and has to find out how
to win this game it seems like the
easiest procedure for this position is
simply to take on E1 and after a capture
on E1 play Queen H2 check King F1 and a
nice moment here there's probably a lot
of wins you'd be thinking but the engine
has come up with Rook takes D4 give me a
pawn would be a beautiful finish to the
game if if you capture back and now
Queen F4 check and you're going to just
get mated in this line wherever you put
your king queen F2 would be mate so
we're waiting to see if this is what
transpires as Katarina studies the
position this will be one for her best
games book for sure if the game
concludes in this kind of style amazing
wellplayed game and we're going to keep
our eye on her and she's reaching now
for a piece it looks like she's
hesitating and it doesn't look like
she's reading reaching for that Bishop
looks like she's going after the queen
and uh she has played it differently
let's take a look at that line guys why
don't you guys share with the audience
what has happened because it seems like
some different moves have been played
either the way what a thematic sacrifice
Rook takes D4 you just you live for that
moments don't oh my God those that those
are the moments why you play chess
exactly and I was just thinking about
how this reminded me of her game from
yesterday it's not that she's winning
it's that she has so many choices on how
to win that sometimes you just choose
the one and only move that doesn't right
and although I'm sure that Knight takes
G5 should still hold some kind of an
advantage it looks so unnatural exactly
she's worked so hard to bring her Knight
to this dominant uh outpost on e4 uh and
she basically said Okay I want to play
Knight takes G5 and you know even as I'm
looking this position okay uh The Rook
takes D4 Queen H2 was so straightforward
everybody goes for it but this looks
crushing as well this looks also very
good I you know I mean we may be
splitting hairs but Knight G5 is not a
bad move it's just that this is such a
oh pardon me uh this is such a a
straightforward and easy one to
calculate you don't once you see the
move Rook takes D4 because you see that
a pawn capture allows your queen and if
you don't take the Rook well thank you
very much the Rook just goes to D2 and
you can uh resign uh Checkmate uh
is in the air um very very very nice
finish completely winning and beautiful
but okay she's doing something a little
bit more more Knight J Knight G5 can't
be too critical that still looks very
good
Maurice well following down this line
the engines are saying yeah she's
killing her in this line too guys relax
because after the queen moves she's
still going to trade she's still going
to play the check and this time she's
gonna play a move you'll like to let me
drop a night in on F3 and that's a
beasty night this night has been dancing
around all game doing the Tango on
Black's position and now she's about to
step on her head because Bishop takes
just going to bring the last piece into
the game and ask you are you going to
resign now or in five minutes when
you're done crying because this is over
fantastic game by Katarina however you
look at it great game to play in round
two of the Championships guys nice uh a
g we unfortunately we we get so many
good great games but one we've ignored
basically since the start uh te Mar garv
who I think is an extraordinarily
talented player somehow in the last few
years it's like he's stagnated he hasn't
really jumped back into the 2700 uh
class that I've been expecting for a
long time playing against Conrad Hull
today they've had uh three games in the
past teamore has won every game
including one in this variation
including the s they've all had uh Slavs
all three games and they play an
exchange SLO
today and I'm moving quickly because I
want to go around the horn here Bishop
E5 and uh White has seated the two
Bishops for this
um this uh what is it a filor attack
what do they call Pillsbury attack all
I'm looking is at a monster Knight on E5
that's what I like yeah exactly and and
Conrad one of the things I think that
really separates the current generation
of players from say a generation of twoo
is their extraordinary defensive uh
abilities in my generation it's sort of
like players
collapsed and today's players they put
up Fierce resistance uh you know 50
years ago we' look at this position and
say you don't want to play this as black
it's just it's just all white but let's
see how Conrad did it because he
actually hung in there very
well they got this
position it looks a little Fearless to
allow white to swing over his Rook the
Knight the queen and just say nothing's
happening nothing's happening black is
basically saying hey I'm actually very
solid on the king's side your Bishop on
D3 I'll I'll allow for the fact that
it's better uh theoretically than the
bishop on E8 but unless there's some
marvelous Bishop takes F5 the bishop on
D3 doesn't do so much um Maurice your
thoughts just trying to keep up to date
guys because things are happening so
quickly in the game between troa and
nitzki again the funky Knights it's the
day of the knights for sure in this
position white is tro he played Bishop
A6 traded Queens in this position and
now Knight C4 attacking this Rook
chasing it back and now the other Knight
to B5 and after Rook moves to d8 looking
like nothing else to do because of the
Knight C7 threat Knight B D6 and those
Knights have truly ensconsed themselves
in Black's territory the problem for
Kaden though is that he has 17 moves to
make in 5 minutes 6 seconds and counting
down very quickly his 30 second
increments for 17 moves uh that's going
to add up to eight and a half extra
minutes but still it's 17 moves to make
in a position where he definitely
definely has an edge but not the kind of
edge that you say I'll just Blitz out
the next few moves so he has to figure
out what to do and not get in too much
time pressure on another board between
where a knight attack happened let's go
back here a knight move happened right
in this position the move Knight to F5
was played by Sam Sevon sacrificing
thematically on that square of course
gakamsky has seen that kind of move
before he commonly draw back Queen F3
King G8 and in this game six moves to
make seon has 22 minutes G has 3 minutes
and 18 seconds so again time pressure
starting to speak and it's his turn to
make a move now uh as our board hasn't
updated as yet but just me talking is
going to take at least 18 seconds which
means that he's under three minutes by
now so time pressure starting to really
make a terrific effect on these games
guys oh I think G is going to be okay
after all it's a very close position
once he declined the night sacrifice I
don't think he's going to be looking at
at it again it seems that he will simply
Shuffle around be able to survive well
into move 40 without any problems it's
only five moves I think in this kind of
positions it won't be that much of an
issue interesting thought there
Alejandra because I'm I'm thinking that
actually Sam has done incredibly well by
getting his Knight to F5 the double
Rooks on the G file permitting this G5
G6 idea only one bad piece for Sam that
Knight on H2 does nothing so imagine
that Sam says okay I'll play Knight to
F1 with the idea of improving my knight
getting it to E3 what exactly is got
going to do about this I mean does he
doesn't really have we've talked about
this throughout the whole variation he
doesn't really have an active
counterplay type of move uh at his
disposal on the other hand you're
talking about good pieces and I want to
point out that the Rook on G2 and G1 are
absolutely fantastic yes agree once the
Knight on F5 is taken it's captured you
don't capture the Knight though I'm
never going to capture the Knight your
Rooks are not good they're not doing
anything I'm just going to ignore your
threats I'm just going to let that
Knight survive on F5 and then I'm going
to say so what your pieces will not
coordinate until the king side is open
for now they're just not doing anything
I'm going to shuffle get the move 40 and
then figure it out all right so let's
just make a a shuffle if we will for
black for a moment King H7 tell me when
you think I should stop shuffling yeah
exactly uh at this moment do you want to
do a rook G8 or something else I I see
your plans I see your idea taking on D6
and putting the other Knight on F5
precisely so but I'm going to go back to
D vet's ideas of the Superfluous Knight
okay you have two knights going to F5
only one of them actually belongs there
what if I just moov to B7 what is your
continuation uh Knight boy7 oh yeah okay
Knight to B7 wow okay H it's not that
it's a good move it's simply a what are
you going to do to me I've got a good
night on F5 but okay
um Frankly Speaking I was going to play
for Knight G4 okay I check myself yeah
so may not be a case of a superflous
knight maybe I have to prep that move
Knight G4 with one more move I don't
want to see a queen H3 check Landing uh
after I've sacrificed a piece so let me
just
[Music]
cut out a queen H3 idea by just playing
Rook G3 and my plan is to play Knight G4
at a certain moment uh still pressure
the US Champion by the way take a look
at the clock two minutes two and a half
minutes for godak kamsky well let's take
a quick look at other games
because action is really happening in in
this game specifically actually we have
a bunch of new moves and okay well so
much for Shuffling no no more shuffling
Knight F5 hold on pardon me when we have
left it King G8 had been played and
Knight F1 as I
suggested got it captured but with the
Knight with the Knight a big difference
in taking with the pawn which would
allow the G6 almost lethal break
absolutely that was we're totally in
agreement about that one you didn't want
to allow the the O the G file to be
opened up takes got a lashed out with E5
E4 the good news here is that it does
open up a bishop and
potentially a
diagonal over here but let's see what
happens after Bishop takes E4 forced and
got kamsky to play and three minutes for
G no no he had took on e4 oh yes he took
on e4 and then who G took on yeah g took
on e4 sacrific sh o very good point
takes C4 and then move Rook E8 simple
chess so actually it's funny how bad
this Rooks on G 2 and
G1 wait a minute hold on I'm going
exchange up I like the Rooks let's
imagine I drop back to F3 for a moment
challenging black what's the followup to
his wonderful exchange
sacrifice if you take on F5 and say well
I'll just play this position and
exchange down and like the two Bishops
that's okay but I'm thinking that might
be playable considering that you don't
have access to the E file that the D
Pawn is so weak it might be possible for
black to play like this right and
apparently we have some kind of new
development in the game Trove against
nitzki okay let's go down quick look at
that right when we had left it uh we
were all a buzz about the the white
Knights handling the hold on I think
there was a position like this this is
where we had left it Knight came to D6
Rook came to B8 to sidestep this idea of
Bishop B7 mhm
Knight came to B7 attacking The Rook The
Rook was driven to the corner
MH Knight jumped back to C I love that
maneuver the Knight on C5 so powerful
it's a it's it's a great Outpost
beautifully protected by the pawn on D6
we see by the way that Anna sheric and
Kate have finish their game it looks
like Anna has lost I do want to see that
end of that game because if I can see
from here there's a queen hanging but it
does not matter yes exactly it seems
like there was a nice Queen sacrifice to
finish off the game and Maurice you have
it for
us uh it wasn't so it wasn't a queen
sacrifice but it was nice but it was
nice because she just played very simply
she didn't do anything brilliant the
sacrifice Rook takes D2 she just said
your position is so bad I'm just going
to mate you and that's what happened
Queen after the Knight went to E4 I
think we left it here she did trade on
E1 that was fine and then she just moved
her night to to block this bishop what
are you going to do you're helpless it's
like a cat playing with a mouse you have
nothing to do the queen moved back to C2
and she just brought a rook in the game
and said it's over and Anna played Rook
A1 and it looks like a queen sack is
actually just made on the board game
over of course the bishop is pinned
because of that rook and the game was
over anyway so a powerful finish for
nemova she is now leading the tournament
at the moment definitely someone who
will challenge for the title guys also
in the women's section I think that it's
about time we take a look at Arena
crusher's game and see if she has been
able to break through Victoria ni's
defense more or less well when we had
left it we had looked at the position
hold on where are
you uh Arena the defending Champion
Arena Crush had come up with this very
nice idea of Knight H1 we had left it
about these parts Knight G3 uh
threatening to play Rook H1 regaining
the pawn on H6 Victoria drop back with
her Queen Rook
H1 okay she didn't want to all to try to
hold the pawn with G5 because that
Knight F5 was uh convincingly good for
white she dropped back with her her King
Bishop takes H6 regaining material
parity but also breaking through on the
king side ooh I didn't expect that one
for some strange reason I thought that
Victoria's plan you mean for some normal
reason for normal reason I thought
Victoria's plan was to bring this Rook
on C7 over to the defense of her King
she did not do that she played rook and
G5 uhoh big news a foot Bishop G4 Bishop
E6 ideas suddenly magically appear Rook
F7 trade trade I feel there's some
danger here I just feel there's
something here Maurice tell us there was
danger here but it did not come with the
move G5 in fact the injuries were saying
that uh Arena blundered not blundered
like she would have lost but blundered
away a huge opportunity to Simply get a
gigantic Edge in the position right here
instead of playing the move G5 the
engines wanted her was screaming for her
to just bring her Rook into the game
this move would have almost sealed
Black's fate the problem is this Knight
on f8 how do you defend if you do
anything at all you disconnect this Rook
from this Rook you're in trouble so if
you play a move for example like Rook to
F7 then simply Bishop takes and you can
see that this Rook is hanging this is a
problem here no simple capture on the f8
Square so first you have to trade off
here but after Rook takes suddenly the H
file is dominated by white and she's
going to get in to this Square her
Queen's going to show up on this Square
as well and there's going to be a big
attack for white in this position she
did not play that she played G5 and that
has pulled back the degree of her edge
quite significantly now the position the
engines are saying it's just a little
bit of an edge for white but time
pressure is starting to creep on both of
them another important game in the
women's contest is between tatev and
Alyssa if I may pull that game up right
here Alyssa uh is according to the
engines Alyssa is now completely winning
cold because of a blunder made back here
well it was a first was a poor move
right here we we were in position like
this pieces got traded off tatv took
this pawn and after Rook to E6 she would
be doing okay if she had play Queen to
C1 check she played Rook f8 not the best
move H3 consolidating this side Alyssa
is always counting on if the queen
leaves she can play Queen to A6 well in
order to help herself she thought she
played the move A6 did tatev Queen
dropped back to E2 and now suddenly this
queen is a much stronger piece headed to
the E5 Square first of all let's just
think Rook takes F6 followed by Queen E8
and H and A8 mate is a threat and now
the move King A7 and the engines go
crazy counting it now a seven-point
Advantage for those of you 7.26 those of
you familiar with engines you know
that's like you can go to sleep now
because it's over what is she to do she
played King to A7 well if the move is
found Queen to E5 Knight's hanging here
C7 Pawn is hanging this is going to be
all she wrote and one of the favorites
of the tournament will go down 02 and it
looks as though the move has been played
Queen to E5 and it seems as though the
women's GM tatev abrahamyan has nothing
to do here this will be a devastating
loss guys completely over Queen E5 very
logical move Alisa finds it without a
problem of course and it just doesn't
seem like there's any way of Defending
Your pieces well I mean when we talk
about tactics what 90% of tactics are
simply double threats and queen E5 is a
very very big double threat because of
the threat of Queen C7 check and mate
and the Knight on F6 is hanging this
game is over uh we had been talking
about uh the game with Daniel
nitzki uh we didn't actually finish with
what had happened in that game although
we do have a move we're seeing Rook C8
but that's uh All She Wrote um when we
had left it we've got to a position like
Knight D6 we were both gushing over how
powerful that Knight on C5 is and Daniel
has just played the move E5 Knight D
E4 67 minutes for Daniel two minutes for
Kaden uh lots of moves to be played but
it looks like uh White definitely for
choice in this game such a weak Pawn on
A7 it seems like also the structure
being threatened on F6 by Knight takes
F6 very difficult position for nitzki
and it's he's also in time pressure I
mean of course we're talking about Tru
having only 2 minutes and 24 seconds and
that's not pleasant by any means but 6
minutes and 30 seconds that also is not
very good not and especially when you're
positioned so bad right we have a
special guest in our audience absolutely
wonderful we move to
Maurice and we are with Karina n SOA
after a sterling victory in her game
against against Anna sheric first of all
congratulations Karina when is the last
time you made it some on the
board I I don't know I don't remember I
I think it's many years backward
probably when you're a little kid right
a Checkmate in in an actual game did she
get confused and not notice this
Checkmate was she shocked when she saw
it yeah I think she just missed that you
know we we were in a time pressure so we
were you moving very fast and I think
she just missed that yeah now you played
an aggressive game today you played H5
H4 then you played F5 then you played G5
what was on your mind all this
aggression what did you drink this
morning well you know when somebody
plays G G3 Bishop G2 and they just want
to play stable strategic position so I
wanted to change the to shift the tempo
you know just to play Fast to play
something tactical Well you certainly
did and then you played this great move
in the game Bishop D6 at some point
sacrificing what did you think about
this move well I was thinking about
taking on B4 but then I saw you know
Queen B3 A3 it's really bad for me so I
I couldn't see what else can I do and I
thought that I didn't do anything wrong
so there should be a move that I should
be okay and then I found a bishop D6 and
I thought well that's excellent because
I will go with F4 and I mean I have
everything I want in a position so
definitely a star move you guys want to
check that out that that moment in the
game Bishop D6 uh yesterday you had a
hiccup I mean you looked like you were
crawling all over your opponent what
happened well I thought I'm checkmating
her with Bishop F3 I just didn't see
that she can play King G6 back what move
number is that for the audience who
doesn't know what you're talking
about when you played
F3
G and I thought I'm just checkmating so
then I kind of was like well it's not a
Checkmate and then I got into trouble
and I was still winning but you know uh
it's very difficult when you have such a
winning position I could just capture
the pawn on H seven and it's totally
winning and then you just kind of mess
up so that was very difficult that's why
in this position I could play Knight H3
instead of Knight E4 getting an exchange
but I just wanted to Checkmate you know
nothing I just wanted to play it for
checkmate well we like checkmates
ourselves congratulations Karina on a
fine game good luck in the rest of the
Championships thank you Karina mova
bouncing back quickly to win her game
now leading the tournament on the women
side guys impressive impressive
performance by Kate impressive style yes
Absol well done well done uh in the game
on table number two uh Wesley slow
Wesley so uh in my view has kind of
taken over the game uh we had left it
about this moment when he had played the
move Rook d8 move we questioned because
we thought Knight D3 was a great
opportunity there was some maneuvering
around nothing special seemed to be
taking play and then
suddenly it's White's Knights that
started going backwards uh first to G3
then to
H2 Black's Rook on D4 takes up this
fabulous Outpost Queen E3 Rook D3 again
squeezing the Queen the queen ended up
going to A7 Queen A7 I'm thinking
Wesley's taking over moves like Queen C3
Maurice what's your
thought well just a quick bit of news to
report as we said time pressure matters
so much and we are seeing it affect the
players for sure and in this game
between arov of V could and Nasi pidi
black is now completely dominating the
game black hadn't played perfectly but
again time pressure both sides not
playing the most accurate moves but it's
certainly black for Choice here but look
at the next two moves Bishop takes on B7
not a great choice for White Queen takes
and now Knight to E4 and the move
D3 just trying to make this piece into
something special but after Knight to D6
this move the game is going to be over
this is a horrible blunder the response
Queen to B4 will end the game and she
has found the move Queen to B4 not only
is she attacking The Rook on E1 that's
hanging but she's threatening a nice
Discovery with this night so if you move
your Rook away where where do you put it
the fork just looks horrible by itself
at any rate Knight in and this queen is
hitting this one on the other side black
is completely winning the KN move Knight
D6 in time pressure costing the
youngster the game it looks like it's
all over guys speaking of all over it
seems we have an important result also
in the women's section there's been a
handshake and it seems like Irena Crush
has beaten Victoria knee in that closed
position maybe she didn't find the the
most accurate move instead of G5 but it
was good enough for her initiative to
crash through and Arena moves to one and
a half out of two very good for the
defending Champion uh I'm still staying
on the table uh uh number two with
Wesley so uh I I really like this move
Queen C3 by Wesley it seems to me it's
setting up all kinds of nice uh threats
not the least of which is Queen takes E1
but also this nasty like Rook G3 you
know you
a a knight on F4 and a queen on G3
against a castle King on G1 just feels a
formidable Force absolutely uh Sam
understanding that things are not going
in his favor as has played Rook E3 and
let me see if I I am up to date and it
just feels like the table is set for
some kind of a nice tactical solution
here uh for black I mean I really like
Black's position very much and I'm
looking for a knockout blow that may or
may not be there but it looks good to me
I like it as well but there is some
pressure on F7 as well and we do have
another result yes when
Maurice indeed it looks like uh the
women are dropping like flies I mean
it's it's crazy uh tatev abrahamyan
going down in her game against Alysa
Melina but let's go to the game between
ireena crush and Victoria KNE who also
just blundered I mean you look at this
position there's a pawn sitting on the
B7 square right the rook's guarding it
so what do you do in time pressure move
your Rook away to attack a random Bishop
what's up with that Queen F2 check King
to G7 and now Rook takes B7 with check
thank you very much the it's just
horrible you can't move your king back
because of Bishop E6 check you can't
leave with your king because the Queen's
coming to f8 so this move Rook H4
Victoria is going to see that move in
her nightmares because now after Knight
d 7 the nice Queen F6 check and that's
kaput because the Knight is pinned you
could always trade but you are about to
lose a piece she was not that much worse
but time pressure affecting the games we
see you could spend a lot of time doing
hard work but if you do not manage your
clock then the famous saying time
pressure makes fools of us all and it's
come to bit to bite a couple of the
women in this round at the tournament
guys thank you so many results coming in
into time pressure and so many blunders
we saw Victoria NE blunder her game away
T Abraham and also blundering her game
away in a very interesting position but
you know again I feel it's the high
tension the high drama of you know the
starting everybody's nervous they are in
good form they want to perform very well
and uh and these are tension induced uh
blunders no absolutely they don't come
out of nowhere part of CH is making your
opponent crack Under Pressure exactly we
saw that uh in those games um at the
moment I you know I'm looking at this
position of Wesley so and I want to come
up with something brilliant and I've
been unable to do so I mean it it feels
like uh the table is set for black to uh
do something marvelously wonderful and I
haven't
found frustratingly
enough a win I sitting there going okay
if I just trade Rooks well I could even
think with the queen I think the end
game is not so bad exactly I'm not that
impressed um I I come down here with a
check uh force and it just seems to me
that well at the end of the day I've
just left my Pawn on F7 hanging and I
I've got nothing that I can be really
that proud of maybe I'm a little bit
better but I feel that I haven't you
know hit the nail on the head with this
particular variation so Wesley so by the
way has been thinking for 4 minutes of
the six minutes he's had he's down to 3
minutes on his clock he's got your
intuition he actually thinks that
there's something there has to be can't
find it right how frustrating is that
that's completely understandable we do
have a few moves though he decided that
he didn't have anything better to take
on E3 which is what you were suggesting
right and shanlin more or less to my
suggestion decided to take with the
queen as in order to not really risk any
of these variations right Knights are
excellent Defenders here obviously
Shanklin has a worse Pawn structure okay
but yeah seems very likely that he will
be tortured but at the same time that he
might
survive I've always I've always
subscribed to the theory that night
endings are like King and pawn endings
if you take off the knights uh could
black win this as a king and pwning game
as a pure King and pwning game that
seems difficult to believe yeah I mean
it certainly in Black's favor but it it
it's in the realm of imagination that
you might get zuk Swang uh with the
Knights however White's got to have a an
issue a longtime issue he's going to end
up let's say after Knight
F1 uh I'm just putting
some uh moves on the board both Knights
both of White's Knights for the moment
are stuck and maybe I should improve my
play I beg your pardon I'll first induce
the move H4 right so now uh if I can tie
you up your king is really stuck for a
very very very long time and that'll be
all very nice but remember that white
has his own threats and I actually don't
threat yeah for example when you play
Knight G4 I'm not going to be so
complacent and move my knight back okay
I'm going to use my knight to defend and
attack Knight G4 I'm going to play
Knight C4 Aha and I think that because
you dropped the TG yeah I have to
prepare it a little bit better I
probably have to prepare it with G6 and
now the difficulty I find for black is
that if I bring my king to F3 suddenly I
have more pieces defending than you have
a
talking well uh controversy here because
I do like Black's uh position maybe it's
not enough for a win that's not a
controversy maybe it's not enough for a
win Maurice what's your thoughts well
while you guys are discussing those
boring end games let's go to a game that
is really exciting in time pressure and
it looks like black is going to dominate
this one you look at this position a
while back we said white looks like he's
trying to do something in the game
between gev and Holt he got his Rook
over to this side he's attacking yes how
can he make something happen and then
black play to move F5 and said you're
never getting in I've got the second
rank controlled I've got the same
structure in the middle as you do you're
not getting in anytime soon well jump
further into the game and white had to
bring all his pieces back away and his
Rook left the F by the way and although
he has a nice Knight on e4 it's black
dominating the C file so what would you
play here this is where Grand Masters
show themselves Holt decided to play the
move Bishop to B5 sacrificing a clean
Pawn in order to unleash this Knight get
this Square for his Knight well okay
looks like both guys have the square E5
for this Knight E four for that Knight
except the difference is we're only
talking about these Rooks now these
Rooks are going to dominate the game it
doesn't look automatic that this is
great for black he is threatening Knight
to D2 so white played Rook D1 only to be
met by Rook C2 and that Rook is now on
that rank he might play a shift at some
point but Rook F1 just defending guess
who showed up the big dog the queen
queen to H4 and now you can feel the
clouds like wait a second what is he
pressuring me here with Rook D E1 was
played and now Knight to D2 hitting The
Rook on F on F1 Rook E2 and now Knight
takes F1 and black is now up in exchange
pure and simple the engin are loving
black so it looks like gev is in deep
trouble here in this position as Conrad
H looks to make his Mark in the
Championships guys impressive play I
loved it Bishop B5 so thematic and
things are happening very very quickly
let's take a quick look at a game that
we thought was just completely over yes
a per could play against Nazi pit
apparently we have a serious blunder in
that position well we left it we thought
uh Queen B4 was a a stone cold winner we
were back at this point uh Maurice was
pointing out that this uh massive threat
of a discovered attack against the queen
never mind the fact that we've got a
runaway criminal Absolut in the position
Rook E4 should not have saved the game
Knight E2 check
nonetheless maybe there was the simplest
was simply to push this Pawn kn2 also
looks pretty good knight E2 was played
Queen E1 running check mid in one move
you got to like that can't say that was
wrong yeah Rook was forced to capture
wait wait why would you take with the
queen that's a very good question I
would have recaptured with the pawn just
to get the pawn
s to coronation
promotion Queen was her choice
ah now it's
complicated whoa a second Knight F6
check what is going on here what is
D2 has uh I'm actually thinking of the
move Queen
E7 does that do anything it threatens
check Maiden one so it definitely does
something my goodness uh I'd have to
play Rook F7 and then white has at least
a
Perpetual after this doesn't she this is
just a this was the Perpetual I was
thinking so errors go lore in time
trouble here and queen e7's a move
without question and what a wow Queen E7
and we actually Queen E7 was played okay
it was played and queen E5 actually was
looking at this Mo Queen E5
controlling uh e G7 absolutely prot here
I thought okay there's this idea of now
catching the pawn because we let's
remember white up a piece right right
exactly that is an extra piece on E8 so
catching the pawn with Queen D7 actually
Queen D7 was played but I thought Queen
d8 was just a much better version of the
same thing What's the diff I think that
you cannot play Queen D5 among other
things because of Knight F6 Knight F6 I
thought there was also this idea of
keeping the The Rook under attack right
right I understand uh but Queen D7 was
play yeah Queen D7 played so let me just
uh let's see what's going on in this
position okay so here you were
mentioning that black does have Queen D5
maybe not Queen
D5 Rook F2 perhaps that's looking pretty
good too again we are a piece down we're
a piece down but yeah very complicated
very complicated position to play in
such a short amount of time without
question and it seems like we do have um
a per your could making time control uh
in the in the position we have a couple
of other moves after Queen E7 Queen E5
and oh pardon me so let me just uh
reclick the game Sorry right so we get
up to date okay so we do have oh I see
so after Queen E7 came Queen E5 what and
queen D7 and black just simply said I'll
promote and recapture my piece but now
looks like even material to me even
material and no advantage you know all
right Maurice there goes you tell us a
little bit about another game yes again
time pressure but this time it's the
curse of the 41st move that affected one
of the players in the game between the
two youngest players in the competition
Annie Wang and Jennifer Yu Jennifer had
played quite well to get this position
with black an he had been kind of
fussing around a little bit and couldn't
find her footing and in this position
it's move 40 it's time for white to make
a move and she's down upon Pawn so she
naturally thought well let me take the
pawn on A5 except now suddenly King C5
and her King finds itself in a mating
net suddenly if this Knight shows up
anywhere it's mate to the king she
played the move B4 King C6 Still The
King is trapped in a cage and now Bishop
to E2 and Knight to D4 and look at that
mate threat on B3 and if she plays
Bishop back to D1 then Zug vong what do
you do nothing to do but seal her own
fate is not her Bishop is completely
dominated any pawn push the king just
waits around and you're in total zugang
now this Pawn push allows this mate so
suddenly the game is over that 41st move
she should have played King B6 and and
try to fight on but now she's found
herself in a very nice mating net guys
wow what an amazing zuk song amazing
mating net that's something you see in
like a kasparan puzzle I'm thinking the
same thing a domination this is not real
life is it no no no that's too pretty
that is very pretty by the way we've
lost uh we haven't much attention to it
when we left it hikaro was so very
winning he was two pawns up uh it looks
like he's still cruising so we have no
difficulties there it seems that it's an
extra two pawns safe King safe King yeah
that doesn't seem like it going to go
anywhere uh Wesley so oh interesting
Wesley has played G
and I like this idea I wanted to put my
king on F3 so as the defend E4 further
and I think he just wants to have this
idea of H5 G4 at some point to kick out
my king right so like H5 so in case you
go will have a G4 type of thing resource
Oopsy Daisy the the pawn on e4 would be
lost so Wesley still trying to squeeze
blood from Stone a bit in this game all
right we have had a draw and now the big
game Sam
seon uh got a kamsky got a a sacrificed
inchange uh it was back in the in these
parts where we thought that God could
just uh keep the position he said no I'm
going to break out he sacrificed an
exchange in a
pawn got the two bees got the pawn back
and got the B back and now has played
Bishop
D3 and now it's time to reassess who
who's better and why I don't know these
two Bishops are very strong and they're
monstrous and that pawn on D5 is going
to surely fall soon exactly if black uh
will try to round it up with a very
direct rook d8 and by the way over on
the queen side B4 this bishop on h8 may
have something to say as well so uh Sam
lost control he was containing G very
well for quite some time but now it
looks like G the rainy US champion
saying I'm a hard man to beat breaking
out breaking out I especially dislike
that Rook on G2 I just want to find a
way to get it back into the game and I
cannot find a path how do you get that
Rook from G2 to somewhere useful very
difficult I think that even though
probably white is still okay somehow
it's easier to play with white for uh
for black exactly it and that's
important that's important that it is
easier for uh for black in this position
got looks very confident in the board
and we have a special guest
Lisa we are with Alyssa Melina after a
victory in her game Alyssa
congratulations thanks Marius now this
game was a little bit wild we were
really intrigued by some of your
decisions in the game particularly the
first decision when you play this move
Rook F to E1 everybody was falling out
their chairs in the studio they said
they would have just taken anyone right
away and and then thought about it what
was your thinking and we go to the board
at this moment when you played Rook T
Rook to E1 Rook fe1 well Rook fe1
invites the trades down the E file but
then you know I'm left with a very
strong queen that is threatening both F7
and D5 and coupled with the bishop pair
it's very dangerous for black so you
didn't care about those Rooks you
thought your queen was the one in this
position yes yeah okay all right so now
you both were in time pressure she in
particular was in severe time pressure
were you surprised she was taking so
long to make moves in this game uh she
was she was starting to tank very early
on in the opening and she probably
wasn't expecting me to play this line
because I usually play the advanced
French I played at all um last year's US
Women's so I'm sure that she was caught
off guard by this and she seemed very
cautious when she was making her moves I
think she could have played more
confidently because most of these moves
were forced so an exchange French
surprising your opponent well it it's
not an a pure Exchange French where I
would take on D5 immediately but it's um
this move order with Knight C3 and
Bishop B4 so it it's quite
tricky wow the position seemed fine for
her if we jump now to uh later in the
game let's see right around here just
before when she took an A3 yeah when she
took an A3 right here if I can just get
the position to come up there we go now
it looks as if she always had a chance
to Propet when you played Rook to E6
were you thinking this game is petering
out into a draw
I definitely saw that she could force
the Perpetual if she wanted to so it was
really her decision at this point but it
seemed to me like she may have been
trying too hard to push for a win maybe
she thought that you know she had she
had the past a pawn she was up a pawn
and maybe after her loss yesterday she
felt the need that she needed to win and
come back so unfortunately she pushed
too hard and ended up uh really getting
devastated at the end uh you had a lost
yesterday as well against the youngster
our Pro over could what are your
thoughts on these young players in the
Championships and they're like little
kids you're all of what 23 years old and
they're making you look geriatric almost
I know I feel old playing against them I
remember when I used to be one of those
yeah now I have to face them but I was
very impressed with her play yesterday
uh she was resilient and she was very
active she wasn't you know trying to jar
anything she was coming after me and she
made a series of very cor critical
decisions at the right points and she
played maturely throughout and I'm
watching her game now and it it looks
like she's keeping it up we want to
congratulate you on your cover story for
chess Life Magazine great photo thank
you uh how are you combining your legal
practice now you're a lawyer
congratulations on that as well having
passed the bar with your chess
activities yes well um it's not easy but
um well I moved to New York since since
I was here last time best city in the
world right and also a good City for
keeping up with chess um been playing at
the Marshall been trying to just um stay
sharp you know playing in tournaments
every now and then but the biggest thing
is that my firm is very supportive of me
coming here and I'm very grateful for
them because after this I'm playing in
the Women's World Team Championships
representing the US I'm flying out for
that April 16th almost as soon as this
is over so I'm taking pretty much all of
April all for chess great firm why don't
you tell the name so that they can feel
good about themselves as well wow what
is the name of your de Boys in Plimpton
LLP they're amazing and yeah also the
cover photo for chess life that was
taken at the offices so they were also
very supportive of that letting the
photographer come in fantastic well
that's what we like to see thanks so
much for joining us and good luck in the
rest of your games thank you the lawyer
and Fay Master Alysa Melina after
winning her game guys thank you Maurice
wow I like that very very
supp a couple of important results
please do have the game of Annie Wang
finishing with a beautiful checkmating
pattern almost a study like position
Jennifer U takes her first victory of
the tournament bouncing back nicely
nicely from uh well a one position that
she managed to lose yesterday right and
also the game between Nakamura and
akobian has finished okay uh very
clearly in favor of Nakamura who moves
to an easy two Z relatively with today's
game and Well he seems pretty much set
to win the tournament Wesley
so okay but he's cruising I understand I
I I just think that if he can't lose
lost possessions and if he wins easily
with white yeah well of course I mean uh
it it's true I mean it it definitely has
the wind at his back at the moment this
is the same hikaro we saw in Gibralter I
mean if you see this the style of games
he's not afraid to take risks he's not
afraid to say I'm the better player I
don't care that I'm not supposed to do
this I'm going to do it anyways come
here and punish me and we see that Holt
couldn't do it akobian couldn't do it
who's going to be able to do it in this
tournament there's something to be there
some guns out there who would like that
opportunity from a good position of
course okay so uh uh hikaro uh to zeip
uh Wesley so did you did you catch this
move by the way by uh Sam Shanklin H
yeah H4 and Wesley said well how about
this how about if I just captured that
pawn now I'm sure when when Sam played
the move H4 his intention was to follow
it up with this move Knight F5 but I'm
just
wondering is is the move Knight takes
E4 uh then available for black after
Knight F5 I could take on e4 I think
right and oops and beg your
pardon I'm forgetting my D6 Spa is
hanging D6 SP is hanging okay King takes
F5 what do you think about uh but Knight
takes D6 keeps it safe and sound right
so sorry so Knight
F5 well hold on do I have another
opportunity KN D5 night D6 yeah and we
do have uh hikara Nakamura the number
one seat in the tournament joining us
and as he was going by the monitor he
said 95
um seems pretty safe for Shanklin safe
well safe is
Rel this is a line being given by uh
Hikaru 97 speak louder Hikaru what
happens
next king F6 iau Knight Knight G8 King
G7
all off with what should be a drawn PA
end
game which should be a drawn PA end game
all right well guess who's in
town he car
Nakamura thanks guys well you know a guy
loves chess when he's paying attention
to all the boards he's just fought won a
a hardfought game or maybe he might not
call it a hardfought game but he's still
quite interested in what's happening on
all the other boards particularly this
game you guys were talking about with uh
number two player in this competition
Wesley so first of all Hikaru
congratulations on your
Win Second of all uh you're did you know
the move B6 when your opponent played it
you seem to kind of lean back take your
jacket off and and went to work when the
move B6 appeared on the board yeah okay
I mean I i' I've seen similar ideas not
in the exact position but um you know
okay it's a pawn so why not why not take
it basically I mean is that how you felt
when you looked at the board you like it
was just the PA yeah kind of I I either
T well not that it's that I saw this
Knight D4 Knight B5 idea um and then I
think my queen sze should be more or
less intact um but kind of I mean what
else am I going to do play C6 or
something and just draw I mean okay I
didn't didn't really feel like playing a
boring game so um yeah I just took the
pawn and I think I mean once basically
when I was calculating this Knight D4
Knight B5 idea and I saw it before I
took on B6 um I just figured it it had
to be okay and I thought it was just a
dubious sack basically and it looked
very much that way eventually did do you
think it was going to be this easy
though because it just he just fell
apart within the next 10 moves really
fast did you see any chance for counter
play well okay after after VAR didn't
play Bishop takes G2 um after Knight D4
when he didn't play Bishop takes G2
after that I think it's just over I mean
I think basically you can play on for
who knows how long but eventually you're
going to lose that position I mean white
just has to consolidate C4 F3 I mean
okay some point I can maybe even go B3
A4 so I just think I mean uh you know I
think really it wasn't V position
basically you know VAR is a very
positional player and so to kind of you
know just Gambit a pawn like this um uh
it's not a style so I think certainly
because of that he was a little bit
uncomfortable and he didn't find the
right continuations and so I mean that's
I think it's more a style thing than
than anything else you know I don't know
if I was playing that position Magnus I
think I would prefer to be black than
white for example but I mean against
positional player like VAR I mean I
certainly prefer white well you
mentioned the number one player in the
world Magnus Carlson congratulations
you're now currently the on the live
rating list the number two player in the
world having crossed a 2800 barrier how
do you what are your feelings about that
I mean who cares I mean I think a lot of
people would care about being the number
two player in the world no they're
better things to do in life than looking
at that stupid rating list frankly um
I'm just trying to play a good chess and
I I'll worry about everything later
you've been playing very good chess this
year having won jalter having won Zurich
by your standers the game in round one
wasn't so great this one was definitely
a dominating performance Alejandro
Ramirez our host even said well hiar
looks like he's on his way to winning
the tournament what are your thoughts
about that wow okay let's just let's
just say the starts very similar to
jalter I started with black had a rather
shaky game won that and then I think in
the second round I won a very nice game
against Hara so um I guess the start is
similar but you know obviously tomorrow
I play G um we we'll see which got shows
up certainly but then I then I play
Wesley as well so I mean there're a lot
of strong players you know it's long way
to go 2 and 0 is not I mean okay it's a
it's nice to start 2 and 0 but I mean
really who cares so I guess you're not
thinking about the Bobby Fisher prize uh
I I I might I might think about if it
was it was a a prize which I think uh is
more accurate to reflect how difficult
it is to go 11 and0 so what do you think
it should be like uh I think the OD I
think the odds should are substantially
higher let me put it that way well
congratulations J game thanks for
joining us and good luck in the rest of
the tournament world number two on the
live rating list at least Hikaru
Nakamura showing uh 2 and0 number two in
the world I got better things to do guys
I think that that's a fantastic success
I mean uh to be the number two player in
the world I have to go back and I'm
thinking about gamsky at the time that
he fought for the world championship
against anat carpo but I always believed
that that Gary Kasparov and Anatoli were
ahead of him in the rating list so that
this is the finest since Bobby fiser I
mean I don't think anybody else um can
claim uh reaching this Summit of number
two in the world who is American so I
think it's just hats off and Well Done
uh very very impressive and a two two
and 0 start is Meaningful and tomorrow
he will have a big match with the
defending Champion god aamy well to
answer his question of who cares
probably a lot of people including me
including us I think that it's more of a
reflection of how he feels on preparing
toward the game he doesn't really care
about being number two in the world what
he cares is playing good chess the
results will come by themselves and
that's very important for a lot of
students that are trying to get good at
chess and they're always like oh but I
haven't hit 1600 I haven't hit 1500 I
mean don't worry about it play chess
rating will come hiar Nakamura just sets
up play good chess and let the rest let
the details take care of themselves so
as we're uh going around the board here
for again uh we're looking at this game
of Wesley slow we've been looking at uh
this move Knight F5 Knight takes D5
variation A variation suggested by
Hikaru as he was walking into the studio
Knight takes
D6 um we were playing I beg your pardon
I think we were playing Knight F6 Knight
F5 um but even the move Knight F5
doesn't really seem to be necessary I
think I can go another another Square
probably what if I just go to C4 your
advantage yes you have an extra Pawn but
it's this doubled pawns on the H file am
I really that scared uh you might be you
might be I don't know uh definitely it's
nice to press of course if you don't if
if you miss the mark well okay you
pressed uh is it that meaningful at the
moment it doesn't appear so but there
are sometimes Knight H2 types of checks
and King G5 King might be able to nudge
you backwards or nudge you in a way that
maybe uh gives something trust me when
you go Knight Knight H2 King G5 I'll go
King F2 King G1 and then the Trap very
happy okay so somewhere between a draw
and some some opportunities for some
opportunities it is important to note
that Shanklin has been thinking on this
move for a while maybe he's just
double-checking that all of his
variation do work with Knight F5 okay
but he got out of uh time control in
move 40 we're on move 44 and he's
already spent uh 13 14 minutes of it a
after having flicked out the move H4
rather quickly right then he went into a
thing hm normally normally this move H4
you think about very seriously and then
you're ready to respond so it reminds me
of his students game or former students
game we know that Sam Shanklin used to
work with Kaden trove
and uh well Kaden did something like
that yesterday right he just blitzed out
basically a moved that very complicated
and then his opponent will took the pawn
and then he went into the think tank
right very very rare sequence of events
but okay it seems to me that shanklin's
position at least is a little bit better
than uh yesterday speaking of Kaden he
is uh
locked uh horns with uh Daniel
nitki at one time I really thought that
Kaden had some very serious
advantages um now less so l so really I
thinking that let me just see what has
happened we got to a position like this
and all of this most of it was under
time pressure we had mentioned that they
were very very low on time and they had
to catch up when all these moves that
you're looking at very very very quickly
exactly so maybe a lot of them in
acccurate but this is the position that
they reached right I was thinking okay
uh White has a pawn no question about
Pawn has a pawn you T to like those I I
very very very much do but I also like
very good uh blockaders the Knight on D6
and okay White's extra Pawn if you will
it's a 3 to2 majority on the king side
if this Pawn on H7 was on a nice Square
light G6 I would think that this is uh
excellent excellent chances for the draw
the problem the problem is this Pawn on
H7 is simply vulnerable in Rook G4 Rook
H4 ideas so okay Kaden he seems to be in
the Dy yes what do you think Daniel
narit is thinking at least with his body
language how am I going to draw
this how am I going to draw this that's
what he's thinking and okay Kaden uh
definitely putting on the pressure uh
other remaining games as we go around
the horn we do have that variation on
our board by the way of Wesley so
KN takes D5 Knight takes D6 just as
hearu mentioned on his way in the door
uh gotsky oh we have a couple of moves
has uh captured the pawn on D5 that Rook
was on G1 what happened okay so Bishop
came down to uh D3 Rook d8 Rook slid
over to A1 V4 you had mentioned this
idea very powerful absolutely Knight to
E4 Rook takes check King H7 Rook E8 Rook
E8 and so we're up to date with this
game well black has a chance to win a
pawn I'm not so sure it's a pawn I want
to take but I feel I can take on e4 and
then capture on C3 at some point uh
which move prob maybe you just start
like this start like that not worried
about him taking with the Knight because
of Rook D4 Rook D4 I believe it yeah
exactly and okay
uh Black's not losing but he's not
winning either this is a this is
everybody's happy with a draw I think
here I think I wouldn't be too afraid if
I was black I would have a nice Bishop
either on B4 or on D4 really dominating
a lot of squares exactly our rook's
probably going to go to F5 hitting F3
the H4 Pawn is weak Rook on C4 is
mediocre to be nice to it uh on the
other hand you can't really make
progress here Down The Exchange right I
think everybody will be happy with the
draw I I I love this uh story of Gary
Kasparov Gary Kasparov was playing in
the
spartakiad Olympiad of the old Soviet
Union and he had Ajman he had bishop and
pawn versus an exchange and he called
his mentor Michael bod linck on the
phone and he hadn't given bod vinck the
position and uh bod vinck uh asked uh
about the imbalance and it was a bishop
and Pon versus an exchange a rook and uh
B vinck interrupted Gary as he saying my
King's on G wanted to binic interrupted
Gary and he said Gary do does your
Bishop have an anchor Square in this
case an anchor square like D4 and Gary
said no and B Vick said you're
lost and Gary
stopped hours of analysis but viick was
right he just understood that the bishop
needed to have an anchor score bishop
and pawn versus Rook but if it wasn't if
it was a free floater and and Gary
looked me and said you know these guys
knew chess they understood CH that
knowledge that serious a sea of Concepts
that they know that it can just be like
not even look at the position not even
and they just pick it out of their
memory bank it was pretty impressive it
was a great great great story but here
the Bishops anchored it seems like he
has a fantastic Square the structure is
very solid for black it should be a draw
agreed let's move let's move onwards for
a moment before we take a break uh just
a second where are we team Mor garv uh
exchange for Conrad Holt not easy to win
not easy to win Knights sometimes
protect Kings very very very well
excellent Defenders also strangely
enough the King on F7 is very exposed
because it needs to be guarded by the
queen and there's always uh some kind of
tricky checks that you have to be
careful about so a game that we had kind
of in a sense notched as a victory for
Conrad is no certainty this is not a gim
me position this looks very difficult to
convert of course black is better black
is definitely pushing for the win but
it's still tricky there's still some
ways that black can overreach right and
underestimate the dangers to his King
this is the team this is the Caden Trove
game which we think that white uh is in
the driver seat nii and a Pera I count
one two three 4 one two three but the A2
is hanging try uh but okay this looks
pretty dra to me right pretty draw
indeed uh this was the Checkmate game
this was the beautiful domination game
where absolutely white walked into a
lovely mating net Arena has
won uh oh Russ we haven't looked at this
game in a while absolutely boy let's
let's go back uh a little while and
let's see how things developed here well
frankly speaking not too many things and
then Bishop takes
F6 Pawn
structure wow it's actually a very
difficult decision to make just give up
your Pawn structure like that completely
changing the Strategic dynamics of the
position absolutely absolutely well I've
been a I've been a big big advocate of
structure uh throughout most of my
career I love having a good uh structure
no and in this case I completely agree
with you this looks very strange also
White's game a little passive don't you
think yes I think that uh this has has
played passively finally finally a break
those Bishops D4 got to like it okay
well you got rid of your structural
weakness also
true and just to regain it oops Bishops
of lap is a color notorious uh for uh
drawing
draws h h H it's hard to say agreed I
think I'm going to just prefer black a
little bit because of this past dewn but
I think this is looking more like a draw
than a victory for either player even if
I can play F4 in this position even if
you can play F4 in this
position yeah it's a very complicated
situation it is true that opposite color
Bishops are very draw especially in end
games but when there are so many major
pieces on the board it's always a quick
initiative and it's a killer because
suddenly all of your squares are so weak
right the player with the initiative uh
can take over all right well all right
we can take a quick break yes exactly
we'll be back we'll see you
[Music]
soon
2014 was a great year for chess chess 24
brought you live live interactive
broadcasts from Top tournaments a Play
Zone where you can take on opponents
from all around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your Chess By solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos chess 24 on mobiles
and tablets most features are free but
limited for registered members chess 24
is offering a special premium membership
for just $999 per month or $99 per year
see you at chess24.com
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world but why
when you can just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor St
louis.com
[Music]
we're back with some of the last games
of the second round of the US Women's
and us open Chess
championships so we got some interesting
games probably the most unclear one
still for me is the night end game yes
between Sam Shanklin and wesle so
definitely when we have left it we left
it um roughly speaking after this H4 G
takes H4 Knight F5 position Knight takes
D5 Knight takes
D6 you were questioning whether that
extra Double H Pawn was meaningful or
not clearly
um Whit's in control uh pardon me blacks
in control but is it enough for win well
let's see how how the game continued
Knight C3 interesting decision uh by
Wesley Knight F5 King G5 and at a
certain moment Knight takes E4 is going
to be in the cards knight uh back to D
Knight to D6 pardon me attacking the
pawn on F7 the king came back to F6
Knight
F5 Knight
E6 okay Knight E6 with a very simple
idea of Knight G5 take e and taking the
pawn on e4 and Sam shankling to play and
not so easy not so easy not so easy yeah
and just by the body posture there uh
Sam kind of like and Wesley's looking
very confident here well that was that
was a nice maneuver with 96 we do have
some comments from viewers at the
moment uh hash chess Champs us chass
Champs you can tweet at
us we got from uh Junior dos bestos
Alejandra knows his stuff well I try it
just goes boss mode I like that boss
mode o I hope uh next year it'll be good
enough to qualify maybe for the
tournament yeah
uh DC PA San does not use engines when
analyzing either just goes B I love that
love it but blue tornado has a very
intriguing question that I would like to
talk about where are the cheerleaders in
the dance squad come on come on Tom our
producer you know I mean we've got some
St St Louis Cardinals cheerleaders that
are doing nothing right now and they
could be joining us here at the US Chess
Championship thank you attive for asking
the real questions yes
exactly and finally we got CH from says
the American production theme is quite
excellent with the flavor of the Wide
World of Sports yes the ABC Wide World
World of Sports with run arage one of
the greatest sporting programs ever in
United States history thank you that's a
very very generous compliment that's
seriously good respect thank you
everybody exactly and it does seem like
Sam Shanklin is just down a pawn yes and
he's facing Knight G5 and no actually uh
this yeah Knight takes H4 was played and
it seems like with this trade of Pawns
black has fixed his structure it's up a
pawn I still think white has good
drawing chances considering the fact
that the material is so reduced but but
we all know how important night endings
in Kingdom Pawn end games are right
absolutely Knight hit takes Knight takes
so a clean extra Pawn clean extra Pawn I
also have some problems with that Knight
on H4 not so easy to bring him back
exactly meanwhile we have a result in
the aera Cod against Nazi P kider I
believe that game was a draw we was
pretty drawish when we saw it last and
yeah Nazi putting the kings in front of
each other yes signaling for the dgt
board that the game was indeed drawn
exactly so
as we we as we
uh going towards the end of the show
Wesley so very very key game if Wesley
can pull this out I mean he'll be
putting pressure on Hikaru and the god
of csky game it's actually two pawns how
did go how did go manage that well in
fact they did follow the line I know but
Rook F five first I like that idea and
we have first picking up a nice Tempo
against the on F3 mhm white was forced
to defend the pawn on F3 now came the
trade now came the trade and Bishop
takes and another Tempo one with the
anchored Bishop on D4 and there is not
enough time for him to defend everything
suddenly with two pawns I think black
has real winning chances that is
remarkable indeed Rook takes
H4 F4 black has real winning
chances if I can get the get the Rook
out
if you can get the Rook out very quickly
we'll go to Maurice Ashley who has
something to show us in the Shanklin
game yes speaking of black having real
winning chances the game with Sam
Shanklin and Wesley so may indeed prove
to be a positive result for black
because Sam Shanklin may have blundered
on his last move take a look in this
position after Knight to E4 with check
by black he's up upon as you said y one
of the classic things we learn about
these end games is that they're really
King and pawn endings even though you
see the two knights on the board and
it's very important that you get
activity for your KN at least and in
this position with his king in check he
had three legal options and he chose one
that cuts off his knight from getting
back into the game quite easily this
move King to F3 and now the move Knight
back to D6 and the engines are saying
that black is already up a piece now if
he could trade off all the pawns can
white then it won't matter he's down a
night but you're not going to make me
but it doesn't seem so easy and the main
problem he has here is if he simply
moves his King out the way he faces this
move E4 and take a look at that Knight
it has absolutely nowhere to go and if
you have to play moves like G3 Knight to
F5 you can't trade because the king and
pawn ending is lost and Knight to G2 and
now King to G5 this night is horrible a
king is about to show up on the G4
Square your G3 Pawn might drop in the
next moment and this is starting to look
really bad for Shanklin so a potentially
decisive result in this game made easier
by an off move by Shanklin guys thank
you Maurice and while you were giving
that excellent uh explanation of what of
how powerful the move Knight D6 was I'm
looking at the board I do believe Knight
D2 check has actually been played not
the suggested Knight D6 that you
mentioned but I was also liking that
move actually because that was the
natural move for the human player right
right that actually looked really really
good because the idea behind night D2
check is that in case of King E2 King G5
as Maurice was explaining you don't want
to trade Knights and get into aing
possibility right and so then King G5
looks really uh very very tempting no
this also looks great and it right
so big big happenings here in this uh
King and ping game uh night and pun
ending and it looks like Wesley might
steal one so to speak you know get a
victory out of this everybody knew
coming into the tournament Wesley saw
hikaro Nakamura two favorites clear but
I actually didn't expect them to both go
two out of two I mean when you yeah not
at the start when you think about it
there's such strong competition they're
going to play at least one game with
black of course I mean is it really
going to be two out of two and look at
them look at them team roll two two
rounds right
Maurice absolutely I really like those
two players in the tournament yeah big
big surprise congratulations grandm you
know how to count rating points well
clearly these two players have been
playing very well Wesley throughout all
of last year he wins the millionaire
chess open gets 100 Grand in the pocket
uh then he goes to vikon Z and shows his
stuff tying for second place there and
coming here showing that this guy is a
great player by the way we should make
mention of the fact that he is also
quite close to being 2800 himself he's
sitting right now number six in in the
world in the live rankings at
2791 a couple of positive results go his
way maybe three wins you can easily see
him going plus three plus4 if not bigger
in this competition with a high rating
and Sam Shanklin has a win here will
definitely give him some points you
could easily see him breaking 2800 in
this tournament it'll be harder for him
to do but we may have at the end of this
event numbers two and three in the world
sitting right here in the United States
of America America an amazing
possibility that we would never have
thought of May as early as a year ago
but with Wesley coming to this country
and playing such fine chess he is uh
along with Nakamura going to be
representing us quite admirably in
future years guys wow I I just find that
a thrilling remark to to say United
States hosted number two and number
three in the world Wesley still got a
lot of work to get there but for the
moment he's doing a good job he has good
chances today yeah when we have left it
again uh some criticism over the move
King F3 by Sam that may have cost him uh
Knight D2 check and we did see this move
King G5 provoking G3 which makes the
pawn that much more vulnerable uh to a
future king G4 then Knight E4 obviously
attacking the pawn here I thought the
problem that white has is that Sam can't
just Retreat the Knight with Knight F3
check because there's no way to guard
the pawn on G3 very unfortunate unfort
very unfortunate so he had to play the
move King F3 and just a second let me
get up to date with the play for a
moment they actually repeated once and
it's uh Wesley to think now he could go
back to 94 which is of course not yet a
three-fold repetition is still
completely entitled to do that and I
think it's still the most likely I'm not
entirely sure what else he can do well
I was thinking I like that line what um
I'm trying to get back to that line that
Maurice mentioned where where black gets
into E5 E4 and then just presses against
the G3 Pawn so let me just play a move
uh with my Knight Knight away sure
Knight C4 I like okay
so pretty boldly stating the obvious I
intend to play King G4 so the diff What
I'm trying to achieve I think is after
F5 play E4 precisely play E4 play my
king to G4 and Route this Knight to a
useful square and this is just not fun
this look looks lost this does look lost
yeah wow it feels like at some point
I'll be able to zwang you the Knight on
G2 has no squares to go to it's even
better if I don't have to play E4
because I'm not going to give up the F4
Square for your knight right so you're
thinking that g you know you might even
just do one of these uh where the night
becomes so so terrible it doesn't have
the F4 square that the H Pawn just comes
gushing up the board and Maurice prob be
showing us uh what's happening in a game
uh between two young players all right
yes it looks like young Kon tro is
bouncing back from uh the beating he
took yesterday at the hands of Ray
Robson but now show his stuff against
Daniel nitzki who had a really bad game
yesterday was disgusted with himself
he's going to be even more disgusted
today because this game is just about
over in this position Kaden up a pawn
pass Pawn on D5 he played the move Rook
H4 threatening the H7 Square after F5 he
swung his Rook to the A4 Square now
hitting this pawn and this Pawn as well
as hanging King F6 was played in the
position Rook takes on A7 Rook to E8 and
now Rook to A6 pinning the Knight King
needing to defend it now Rook E3 check
look at that skewer Knight to E4 and now
the winning line according to the
engines just simply runs Rook to E6
trade off these guys and if you take
here that pawn looks very fast obviously
then simply have three give me the piece
game over this looks like it's truly
done and Kaden is just kind of relaxed
looking around trying to make sure he
makes the right move here and instead of
going after the piece he just took on e4
not finding necessarily the best line he
still a couple of Pawns up we'll see if
he can continue the game uh looks like
he's reaching for his Rook to trade off
in this
moment and he has done so and he's going
to go up pawns but not as not as easy as
it could have been for him looking quite
Dapper there isn't he I might have to go
get that jacket somewhere guys well I
think that once you find the winning
line or as winning as this variation is
you just sto looking two extra pawns
easy winning you just kind of expect
nitzki to resign it's two pawns true
enough exactly and uh the old expression
is one win per game is all you'll need
so if you find a clear for yourself a
clear wi go for it and uh I preferred
what uh Maurice was saying don't give up
the bishop keep that F2 F3 uh in reserve
but this is good enough uh we're
splitting hairs uh da definitely uh two
pawns down losing I want to go back
again to the Sam uh Sam shacklin game
for a moment because we have seen that
variation by the way no he put the
Knight on e4 instead of C4 and then and
just went F5 which looks very logical it
does I think this is almost reable but
there's one uh key difference here
though uh after King G2 you don't want
to play King G4 because you give me this
Cheapo I get I get to go Knight F3 and
and you know trade that E5 Pawn for the
G3 Pawn well that's nothing so so after
King G2 I'm worried about the move
Knight to D2 absolutely dominating white
exactly now the Knight on
H4 um you can't go F3 and if you do
something bad like King here you
mentioned the zuk's
and I think we're about to see1
absolutely Knight F1 yeah Knight G2 and
I think that the simplest is probably
just going to play E4 and abely
domination
so well guys big result in it seems as
though gakamsky couldn't extricate his
Rook from the H4 square and the game has
ended in a draw so Sam Sean the youngest
player in the competition playing the
veteran of the tournament and he has
managed to hold the game and got to feel
pretty good about that result especially
after his loss yesterday we know got is
going to face a big test tomorrow he
should have the white pieces against
iaru Nakamura so that will be a critical
game for his station in the
Championships guys thank you that was a
game by the way to play today between
Sam Sean and gotsky I think it's a game
that both players can feel good about in
the sense that Sam seon he kept the US
champion under pressure for about 30
moves got uh resilient as always shows
his resourcefulness comes out with this
exchange sacrifice and um a wellplayed
game just a good good drawing game and I
think both players can be pleased with
the result no absolutely it was a
fantastically played game I love kamy's
boldness in time pressure severe time
pressure go for this exchange sacrifice
not being afraid of the the
complications knowing his pair of bishes
would be at least enough to hold
equality and well uh savan finding his
way out of a little bit of a pickle I
think just being able to hold on to the
draw and wonderful it seems that even
though Wesley saw maybe had an easier
win in his position still like his
position as probably just winning let's
take a quick look at the Conrad HT game
which we haven't looked at was the extra
exchange ahead right see if there's been
any progress when we left it uh Al and
Ro we were back around these
parts and uh we you had mentioned uh
quite uh clearly that black has a little
problem with this King and it seems like
Conrad with this move uh King E8 was
looking to try to tuck his King away
somewhere trying to find that right
vicinity of the board to place his King
is broken now with G5 and we have this
position it does feel like black made
least a little bit of progress I I like
that White's King feels even more
exposed with ideas of f4 okay I
especially like the fact that his King's
a little bit more tucked away and I
especially like the fact that tear GV
has 3 minutes and 40 seconds to play the
rest of his game of course with a 30
second increment exactly not a lot of
time no it doesn't make it easier uh one
bit when you're behind on the clock so
definitely things going um Conrad's way
in this game and let me just how the
heck did uh Daniel managed to get his
King to F3 still winning but I am not
terribly impressed with the techque wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute how
on the earth did that happen so two
clean extra pawns Daniel has no
chances and we're here and then we're
going to skip to Black's King
suddenly becoming very active well I
would not have allowed this maybe it's
winning still but this is not the
technique that you you that you want
okay I Marice is saying it's still
winning but I this is not the winning
technique I course it's winning there's
no doubt in my mind it's winning that
it's not so much about it it's that well
make it easy on yourself yeah exactly
what are you excited about a black king
sitting on G2 I mean it looks like it's
it's hiding as far as possible from when
the white Pawn Queens so that the mate
is as long as it will take for you to
win this is over he's just going to
bring his Rook back and then push his
pawns this it's not like he's getting
some dramatic counterplay against those
g& H pawns oh no look out I mean it's
it's over that's done i' like the way
Marie said okay as soon as I promote my
pond and I'll show you the Checkmate you
can tell me about your dramatic counter
flight at least it's far away but yeah I
agree okay nitzki is a little bit due
here resigning but I know know that he's
one of those players that really likes
to play on even though when he's lost so
we'll see probably a few more moves okay
and finally we'll take our last look at
the Wesley so game uh they' re the
players have reached move 60 although
that's not the case anymore that's not a
Time control anymore the the secondary
time control is 30 minutes for all your
moves for the rest of the game including
a 30C bonus increment for each move you
make so King F2 and we're
expecting what what's the simplest or
what's the best I'm not entirely
sure wait
because no you cannot go King G4 because
of Knight G6 okay let's see that King G4
Knight G6 what is wrong or bad or good
about this obviously this Pawn on E5 is
hanging that's not a good thing I'm just
thinking Knight F3 no I agree I don't
want to allow your knight to escape
Escape it's
prison um can we fall
back on our old but now the Knight on D2
I would prefer the Knight to get to the
D3 Square okay let's try this one let's
try check King here I'm not saying this
is the only move Knight back and what's
the difference the difference that I
want to
show is that in this type of position I
dominate The Knight with knight uh D3
check
followed by King G4 I think that that's
okay the winning idea let's go back a
little bit you want to play Knight
C5 yes okay hold on I agree with this
okay but after 94 check hold on uh sorry
when you play okay hold on we're we're
here right cuz I really want to bring my
knight to F3 to be able to keep your
king at Bay right after Knight E4 check
can I maybe go to G2 okay hold on Knight
E4 check good go to not F3 as previously
recommended King G2 fair enough
okay now I'll do my little
maneuvering uh Knight C5 Knight three is
a check so I have to go back okay I play
something like well at least here you're
night after a move for example like
Knight D2 it's not stuck on this
horrible feel a little more confident
without actually having drawing chances
here because I got my knight out and I
cannot figure out how to keep this
Knight
trapped okay so let's because the Knight
is on e4 the variation we were looking
at that Knight was on C4 allowing us to
play E4 trapping the Knight right so
King
F2 and well the problem is well let's
just take a look at the direct let's say
E4 just in this position right Knight
G2 right
maybe but okay Knight G2 seems like I
have to bring the Knight out at some
point okay exactly so I'll put my king
on a on a nice Square G4 then I think
your Knight's a little too far away to
create problems I think I'm going to go
Knight F4 clear clear okay now how do
now this Knight is silly see when the
Knight was somewhere more useful and
attacked
G3 then we can be talking about a
winning chance but uh what what exactly
is your plan here
indeed I want to get my knight to D3 is
my plan okay well Maurice maybe has any
a little insight on how to do things all
right my insight is that uh there
doesn't seem to be any way to do things
in fact uh that natural move we talked
about Knight D2 may have been winning
but it looks as though it's not the most
accurate and he may have slipped it was
the natural move for all us humans a
nice idea Knight D2 check remember right
here he played this move move so that he
could play the move King G5 but after G3
not allowing a force trade this maneuver
now was not so easy remember you can
trade off all the pawns you want but if
you're left with only one my knight is
sacrificing itself for it so he had to
prevent that idea so on you know we we
hate these engines we look at them and
then they say yeah well but he could
have played another line it would have
been much better because right here
after the move King to F3 the the
correct move or the the simp the most
precise move on the board was this one
just dro the KN back and trap this
Knight by playing the move E4 we saw
this line before uh this king is on a
bad Square it has to move trying to get
this square but now E4 and we talked
about this problem after this move offer
a trade send this Knight on the wrong
trip and if he comes out your king just
marches it was very straightforward he
was getting that position you guys are
trying to get now no need for the pawn
to get to the F5 square and hamper
things the night is a dominant piece but
right now the engines are turning away
calculating the position and not finding
anything for black it's saying Black's
in in the other position black is up a
piece in this position black has a one
Pawn Edge well we know that already and
no way to make progress that it's
finding in fact the in are suggesting
bringing the black king back to F6 of
all things and not even finding anything
there either so I think that it's
possible that Wesley has blown this
ending and he may not win as he was
supposed to guys wow that's a big big
slip unbelievable I would thought well
six in the world almost 2800 right it
just shows you that chess is always
tricky it doesn't matter when you're
playing a game that's this long yes it's
very difficult to keep your cool and we
do have finally a handshake in the uh
nitzki game Kaiden trough one with the
white pieces so a shout out to Kaden
congratulating him
now I mean it's remarkable that subtlety
between Knight D2 and Knight D6 uh
really the Knight d2 move is such a
human move I mean you can't blame Wesley
but in fact just because of what you're
saying he's 2,800 he has to blame Wesley
he has to blame himself and when I was
looking the webcam there for a moment it
looked like
Wesley was was doing a pensive Rec
recalculation like where did I go wrong
where did I go wrong it was like yeah
definitely I had this type of thing and
Sam will be thanking his lucky stars if
he does manage to hold this he still is
going to be tested I oh absolutely it's
still only he only has a few minutes
left I see four or eight minutes and 4
seconds on his clock which is sometime
but still it trickles down and it will
be here for a while I mean is going to
run down his clock there there there'll
be a lot of moves to come still in this
game I don't know are we going to have
Kaden uh joining us have we been told
wonderful we will in fact have Kaden and
by the way do you 16 17 years old Kaden
how old is Kaden these days Kaden I
believe is 16 wow I might be wrong
playing in the second us Championship I
believe yeah that's right both Sam seian
and Kaden trough playing in their second
us Championship I actually played Sam in
the in his first one in his first game
ever in the US Championship really yes
and and he drew me oh wow it was it was
the only game in that tournament where I
actually lost rating for
points very good very good well my
feeling is even though that this us
Championship is the strongest and most
youthful us championship by by ELO
rating I think and I really mean this is
that a lot of the players in the field
specifically Sam Sean is still
underrated that they're on a a
trajectory of growth and I'm going to
expect that
in next year's us Championship you're
going to see Sam Sean closer to 2650
than where he is currently at
2585 he's he's he impresses me a great
deal he's currently at 2585 something
like that is he and his feder rating
yeah I think so that seems a little high
to me but he just played T Steel where
he had a very nice result and he had
passed through the 2500 585 didn't this
guy just make grandmas yeah months ago I
mean but whenever you whenever he it
seems like wherever he's been playing
he's been gaining rating points from
each and every uh that's all you need to
do is consistently gain rating that's
true he's been he's been Unstoppable in
most of his tournaments just gaining and
gaining and gaining okay let let's
buckle down here with Wesley so for a
moment and understand this position
you're Pawn up you got to be thinking to
yourself you know I'm going to put as
much pressure on my opponent as I
possibly can to to win the game Let's
analyze this one again okay we kind of
like rejected it a moment ago after King
E4 what do you reckon here how how is
white going to handle
this I got a cheapo for you okay all
right I want you to fall for this Cheo I
want you to go King G2 oh my God I was
going to play that so I could play H4
okay I fell for it
yeah so that that's my Cheapo that I'm
thinking that
if I can provoke you to move your
knight I'm just
wondering can I do something Shifty
myself I will always try to go back to
G6 I believe right yeah that's the yeah
that's the the most annoying way okay
now I have to go night here like I say
it's going to be a long game it's not
going to be you know just you know
you're making a very easy draw or
something like that definitely going to
be some frauding I just think that well
fact you have a knight on F7 something
tells me nothing went wrong for you
right I or it's not going particular let
me let me bring my knight yeah let me
bring my knight back maybe to E7 get it
some activity get it to
C6 I think that well as Maurice was
saying the engine was starting to think
that maybe black had to bring his King
back anyway so but not actually making
progress it was just bringing the king
back yeah well and here Maurice is with
uh very important player of the round
winning his first game in the 2015 US
Championship Kaden
trough indeed we're with a 16-year-old
kayen trough man turning into an old man
already I somehow I I am I I still
thought I was a little young still could
you know enjoy life a little bit but now
I'm like
rushing must feel that way the youngest
us championship in history and at the
same time the strongest what does it
feel like to be playing in such a
competition um I mean it's it's great
like going in into it a little nervous
cuz I I am one of the lower rated but
you know at the same time it's just like
a great opportunity because you know
guaranteed to play all these strong
players which you know how how many
opportunities do you get to play all
these good players in one tournament
it's just it doesn't happen I mean
absolutely I think it's going to be
happening for you a bit more often with
these kind of results yesterday you had
a tough game bit rough you went into
this line first tell us what were you
thinking when you played this move D5
did you think you had a real shot here
um yeah see I I really just I don't even
know I don't even know how to explain
that cuz like I mix something up but at
the same time I I like should have
thought it through um because I thought
like I thought the line went Rook G1
Rook C8 King B1 and then D5 which I was
right but even after King B1 I should
still play Rook C8 because D5 I I
thought okay he's played King B1 D5 of
course works and um just like he took
and I'm like wait a second what I what
was I thinking and so yeah I mean it's
it's pretty much just one of those like
really disappointing things overall um
you know coming into this game I didn't
feel too bad because it was it was
really dumb I mean it it was but at the
same time it wasn't like I just played
terribly um it it was
just and so I'm like you know I'm white
tomorrow um and you know just have to go
in and keep fighting because 10 more
rounds really that first round
um you got to get it out your system you
start bleeding and the sharks smell
blood well you were playing against
Daniel nitzki another youthful player in
this competition he started off terribly
as well did that feature into your
thinking going into the game like well
we both lost so uh he's he's not
necessarily in High Spirits either um a
little bit I I guess so I mean you
always have to consider those things but
it's
also um I know it's hard to say because
I I didn't feel like he he really played
bad in his first game EI I mean he he
kind of did but I think it was more like
you know I'm playing Wesley so oh my
goodness Wesley so played like some
weird opening and um I think in a little
bit he kind of panicked and um you know
once he settled down he actually managed
to fight back and almost draw the game I
mean he's a really strong player so he
still fought back against Wesley so but
uh yeah kind of going into this game um
I I think the the biggest influence like
both us losing really had is that you
know when when it comes down to it I
need to make sure I just don't lose and
you know I'm sure he's you know he's
kind of feeling the same way like a draw
will just be good kind of you know head
into recover from that loss um and so I
I was kind of seeing like you know maybe
I just want to play solid or but I I
mean there was actually a point where we
repeated and I I'm like okay I have to
go for it um so yeah I think it plays a
little bit into I but not really I mean
I'm just you also in time pressure this
you were a big time pressure this game
what was that like I mean it was hering
you were down to maybe seven minutes for
17 moves or so that uh that can't be
good for the for the heartbeat yeah um
in all honesty I guess that which is one
of the reasons I like really wanted to
trade Queens because I'm like okay I'm
probably slightly better but I he always
has like Knight takes D4 ideas and you
know different sacrifices and you know
my time's taking down I'm like I just
have to get the Queens off the board and
um you know it was it was tricky and you
know especially when I I get into this
end game I'm better um it's really scary
playing in that time pressure like am I
going to mess it up am I going to just
completely missed something and um
thankfully like coming out of it I just
was up a pawn had a solid position I'm
like okay we're we're good indeed and at
the end you were up two pawns and he was
still playing on but clearly you were
winning EAS easily what one final
question what are your thoughts now that
you talk about a great opportunity to
play these players do you look at guys
like hikaro Nakamura Wesley so gakamsky
and think I'm here like wow um yeah a
little bit I mean it it was a little
more a little more uh manageable before
Naka and so decided to play but um you
know at the same time while it is like a
great opportunity it's almost
terrifying
um I I I really you know I I hope to be
here and I guess because I I hope to be
here you know now and in the future um
that really like do I really you know am
I really here it's just like yeah okay I
mean I if if I want to be here if I want
to you know be here in the future I just
I have to accept it play good chess and
see what happens well showing that you
belong winning today's game we wish you
luck in the rest of your games thanks
grandmas Kayon tro he will be a rennial
representative here in these tournaments
in the future for sure winning his game
guys back to you what a wonderfully
articulate mature 16-year-old my God I'm
looking at Caden I'm thinking to myself
I wasn't even close to that level of
maturity at 16 wow very very impressive
and you can see it in his moves you know
they're all very meticulous or very
calculated no he's shown a great deal of
maturity not only in his interviews but
over the board without question without
question so as we get ready to kind of
wrap up the show we're still in this
night ending that's a key remaining game
it what would you say closer a draw than
a win or I think it'll be a draw you
think it's going to be a draw
unfortun it appears that way to myself
as well uh again we'll leave it right
here we've had these last few moves
Knight C4 Knight E7 you mentioned this
move and this Knight on H for as long as
that Knight on H4 was coralled if I can
use that expression uh I really like
Black's chances now with this Knight on
D5 I just think that there going to be
too many uh resources for white to be
able to sacrifice his Knight and and get
some pawns Maurice uh final thoughts on
this night
ending well it looks as though it is
going to be a draw it it just seems hard
to make progress but I'm sure Wesley so
is going to make a push but overall
we're still seeing exciting games here
at the Championships uh first round was
crazy we had a lot of wins in today's
game a couple of fine performances I am
really impressed to me the game of the
round was the one that Karina andova won
that one was was just a dominating
performance with lots of beautiful moves
bold Pawn play and and a mate at the end
how often do we get to say someone got
mated on the board so and also the
youngster winning kayen Trove and Sam
seon drawing his game so a lot to look
forward to after round two only at the
Championships nine rounds to go is going
to be electrifying I think as the
tournament goes on
guys thank you absolutely I think this
been fantastic games in both sections
but I have to agree with Maurice game of
the day Hanah shich katr n Sila agreed
all around wonderful job thank you Kate
and thank you all for joining us we'll
be here tomorrow for the third round of
the 2015 US Women's and US Open
championships join us at 12:50 p.m.
tomorrow live from St Louis and I hope
to see you there
[Music]
okay